thank you
hey everybody and welcome to uh Bonkers
wild ride with Stevo Oliver tree is
Bonkers and man I heard all about him
trolling people I legitimately
researched the guy I genuinely expected
that I was kind of sit down in the van
with him and just have him like just
mock me like you know troll me like make
a joke out of our deal and that is
totally not what happened if anything I
think we can safely say that uh there
was an instant connection and and uh the
guard was dropped I mean the guy's
hilarious the guy's hilarious and is
very clearly uh you know having a laugh
but man we also I believe revealed the
true Oliver tree
and uh man this dude is an artist with a
capital Z so let's get into it
all right dude we're wrong Dive Right In
huh let's do it
ladies and gentlemen Oliver tree
what's going on yeah dude we've never
met huh we have not met before that
we're both like thriving in the action
sports Community stuntman yeah obviously
you're the real stunt man but I do say
I'm a I'm an amateur level stunt man
clowns clowns I did go to clown college
yeah so we have some similarities
there's some parallels there we've we
both make music I know and I actually
listened to your rap album you've got
some crazy stuff man
I'm really impressed actually that you
know the diversity is there you've got
quite the
um the Rolodex and the portfolio speaks
for itself well thank you um it's pretty
gnarly because the my rap career really
was the darkest like most like just
gnarly chapter of my life and when I
bring up my rap career like nobody knows
about you're the only person I've asked
on this podcast if they knew about me
rapping I also know about your time with
the Wu-Tang Clan yeah nice yeah
obviously more people know about that
more people but you know that's part of
your rap career that is that is but this
isn't about me this is well it is kind
of all right I would say so what is it
called the show yeah that's true Stevo's
Wild Ride yeah
um now uh dude you're you're uh an
impressive guy man we kind of learned
about you and um like nobody ever knows
when you're serious like uh it is that a
lot of work
um I wouldn't say so no no like I mean
I'm serious I'm a serious dude right but
a lot of things we say it seem to be not
true well that's we don't have any way
to verify that well that's not true I
mean how would you know it's kind of
hard right well I mean there was a large
period of my life where I was not on the
internet so it's hard to really be able
to track back to what happened during
those years those formative years right
your grandparents were onion farmers yes
that is correct that's true how did you
know that I would I did a little Deep
dive myself okay and both of your
parents were trapeze artists oh no my
mom was and my father was a ringleader
at the circus nice which circus oh the
Dell pickle Family Circus nice it was
Northern California based
um but yeah that's I mean you you are
quite an impressive
clown yourself I mean what was the
school I went to Ringling Brothers and
Barnum and Bailey clown college and
um I did not uh work for the Ringling
Brothers and Barnum and Billy circus
I wound up working in a circus at a flea
market in South Florida and then you
ended up on a cruise boat uh other way
around first was the cruise ship then
was the flea market circus and they
kicked you off the cruise boat yeah they
kicked off the cruise boat and said the
next best thing was the flea market
circus but you know I think about this
often it's like
think about how lucky you are that these
clowns band together and cut you off
because what would be you know your life
right now if you had been the lady clown
there how where do you think you would
be
you would you still be at the you know
would you be on the cruise boat still
it's an interesting question man because
um
uh I do believe that I am just
such a persistent attention that I
would have figured out a way to uh
to survive and you know maybe it's
almost a shame because you could have
taken the clown level to another place
but I think you've done that yeah you
kind of are and I think of myself as a
modern clown as well in a lot of ways I
mean even with the way that I typically
present myself very clown-like you know
big suits ridiculous stuff I mean it's a
different version of a clown there's
different types of clowns you know I
would do I love what you do let me tell
you that I love what you do I love the
way that uh
that it's legit music but that it's you
know you're having a laugh you're not
taking yourself too seriously I think
there's enough people trying to be cool
and I feel like Cool's been played out
since James Dean probably like it's kind
of for me like I'm just so bored of it
I'm like what else and I feel like
there's been so much
people trying to sell sex and trying to
sell like this idea of cool that I'm
good I don't really need to cover that
that's not really that interesting from
an artistic standpoint because when
you're an artist everything you do is
Art you know I had a friend who once
said the way he eats a banana is Art and
I didn't understand that at first but
like everything we do is art piece and
so that took me a while to click but now
I see it I'm like oh if you make a
sandwich that's a piece of art you know
obviously when you go to a high level
Michelin star Chef that's art obviously
but when you get someone who makes a
great McDonald's burger that's art when
you see like an athlete play a sport at
its highest level like you know you
don't think of football players as
artists but when they execute the
perfect play when they execute it in
such a way that's like you know almost
like a ballerina dancing through and
executing the ball to the other side
there's art to that you know so as I've
gotten older I've recognized that
everything's art so as an artist my duty
is whatever I do if I'm gonna do an
interview that can't just be a means to
an end for press it needs to be an art
piece yeah
speaking of football players as art I
like a Tom Brady and I see beautiful art
he's a genius she's gorgeous a beautiful
sculpture I mean dude he's gorgeous
right and like I it's crazy it's crazy
yeah
um
your buddy when he eats a banana like uh
he's probably not eating it that's why
it's hard well it's crazy because when
he told me that I was like that's some
oh yeah you can swear oh my God
you said no swearing no no if it's at
the very beginning I was surprised a guy
like you was saying that's right I know
you're a YouTuber so you've got to keep
I was gonna ask you
what did your friends and family think
about when you basically became a
YouTuber were they concerned about you
what were people in your world or were
they like what are you doing Stephen
because obviously a while back right was
there some like legit concerns from like
the Inner Circle that is so funny dude
what a wonderful question remember were
your parents worried about you when you
became a YouTuber what's quite an
interesting trajectory you know I mean
dude at the time I I got into YouTube My
First Youtube upload was 10 years ago
this month wow like I should really make
it 10 years on YouTube thank you and um
at the time of course that was uh 2013.
like
it was I was in a bad place I had a dark
year that year like um Knoxville was
making the Bad Grandpa movie without the
jackass guys it felt like
we got Timber laked wow you know uh I
felt like I was the Jackson four
and um then uh I got like a guy got
kicked off The this TV show that I was
hosting what one was it it was called
Killer Karaoke where people would sing
karaoke while terrible things happen to
them
um and I didn't want to do anything with
animals anymore instead they were like
okay we'll get rid of you and replace
you and we'll keep doing stuff with
animals
um so like I was trying to like pitch
stuff and nobody would want what about
Dr Stevo Dr Steve where was that in that
trajectory was that before that was
before I got clean and sober that that
happened back in 2007. and then Killer
Karaoke was killing karaoke was uh I
shot it in 2011 and it didn't come out
until 2012.
um do you make good money off Killer
Karaoke or was it yeah it was decent
yeah I um yeah it came out like November
2012 and uh then 2013 they they came and
me I've said 2013 and and um
a couple people told me about getting on
YouTube and I was just like man I'm like
I've been like I've had like TV shows
with my name in the title like I've had
like number one movies I'm now gonna
upload the YouTube it felt like so
depressing but and you know like I just
didn't really I didn't think that there
was even like money in it I just thought
oh I'm gonna try and get views on
YouTube you know like what made you
finally click to do it not Sam macaroni
Sam macaroni yeah do you know him no but
I'm getting hungry
damn bro yeah like he taught me how to
edit and somebody and dude it brought
about a complete rebirth for me and and
my career like uh now I now I I identify
as a YouTuber well the thing is
YouTube's bigger than television now I
mean Mr Beast destroys the ratings on
probably any television show besides the
Super Bowl or something I don't know I
think he even bites the Super Bowl right
there you go yeah yeah it's crazy you
were ahead of the Curve I think you've
been in ahead of the curve in a lot of
different ways over the years but that
one specifically I think you really hit
it at a sweet time because now it's like
when I think about my album that's
coming out and I do press around that
I'm not even bothered with anything
conventional press outside of YouTube is
the only thing that matters to me I'm
like that's where the kids live that and
Tick Tock is pretty much where the youth
is so it's like if you think is a kid
going to be watching this like early
morning or late night TV show forget
about it you know do you say that
because you've had a bad experience with
the Stephen Colbert show I had a few bad
experiences I almost got sued a few
times I was like um my guy Isaac who's
who's masterfully running the the
internet on this TV I'm so excited about
it we've never done it in the van I love
it he showed me uh at first he told me
that you got in trouble with Stephen
Colbert you're banned from the students
for some bit that you produced well I
had sent them a script that I wrote for
it and was like hey is this cool they're
like yeah it's great we love it and then
when they saw what it really looked like
it was maybe a little different story
but um it was during the time where they
were filming things
um off-site during covid so I was like
able to use my production company alien
boy films to produce it myself and I was
like oh this is great I get to really
have the ball in my court I had done
multiple late night shows before that
and one time I almost got kicked off The
Late Late Show as well
um because I was on stilts you know as a
fellow circus man I was like what could
be cooler than doing a performance on
stilts and they said you know they knew
I kind of wanted to do a little stunt
potentially and they were like if you
fall off your stilts we're not using
this
um we're gonna kick you off the show and
I was like okay it's over I can't fall
on the stilts during my performance and
I was playing the show and I'm I'm like
in the middle of the performance on
television and then my wig fell off
because I don't I never actually had a
book that I always would wear a bald cap
so people thought I had a bowl cut but
it was basically just this bull cut and
malfunction fell off while I'm
performing like right at the beginning
of the thing and I'm like oh all
right that already was like a left swing
I wasn't expecting but then I'm going
I'm like this is my one chance to be on
stilts on television like how am I not
gonna fall you know I'm like this is the
perfect opportunity what else am I gonna
do it's not that interesting to see
someone walk on stilts I've seen you do
it tons of times you've never seen me on
studs without me falling exactly and
that's the only good part you know so it
was like at the end of the thing I was
like I have to fall even though in my
mind going into that performance I was
like there's no way that I'm gonna fall
I don't want to jeopardize this this is
a big moment and then well happening I
was like when else am I gonna be on
still it's on TV yeah it's like uh Jim
Morrison on The Ed Sullivan Show don't
say don't they they said growing
couldn't get much higher yeah they were
they were nervous about that but yeah
they were like you need to like the
union guys were like we're gonna shut
this down if you fall because I
didn't have you know the proper
insurances or things around it they were
it's a for them it's a security uh yeah
it's quite risk and then presumably you
were walking on Durham
it's actually a prototype I'm not really
supposed to talk okay it's my buddy
makes them in his garage okay Santa Fe
um I saw uh you had like the world's
largest scooter yeah I built that I won
the world's record with the Guinness
World Book records but then they almost
sued me too that was a crazy situation
yeah yeah why would they see you because
I had filmed the I want I got the record
before I had announced it and then I
filmed like a Hollywood version and
um you know because I wanted to do it
right like this was uh during the actual
shoot of it and so the guy if you click
on the IMDb link that right there is uh
no go down
yeah that's Randy rigatoni so this guy I
found him on Craigslist and he said he
was in the French cousin no no he's not
related but this dude I found him on
Craigslist he said he was an official
and as it turns out when we were filming
it
the dude literally had no affiliation he
had the whole outfit and everything I
had nothing to do with that he comes in
he's like yeah I'm an official we can
make this so I had this guy who was
claiming to be a Guinness official Randy
rigatoni came on and it was
because then they made me take
the episode Down so it went live was
broadcasted onto YouTube while it
happened and then basically Randy
rigatoni screwed me and it was taken off
YouTube for at least I think probably
almost a year maybe more and then I had
to cut out Randy Tony take out all the
Guinness logos and all this stuff and I
had to have people like
trying to edit out VFX out their logos
it was this huge nightmare situation I
had to trim all of the footage so that
Randy rigatoni no longer even exists in
the video so but you did end up with the
record I have the record yeah good how
much does something like that cost you
do you want to talk about it but I
usually don't like to say numbers but it
was upwards of half a million for that
for that scooter yeah those are Harley
Davidson motorcycle wheels the whole
thing is made out of nuclear grade
titanium so like the actual build on
that took a team of 15 different
Engineers it was a nightmare and
it shouldn't be that complicated right
clear grade titanium yeah do you still
have the scooter of course I have it I
where are you familiar yeah I'd like to
think I still have it I think I could
sell it for a lot my idea was I was
gonna sell it as an nft that came with
the this is during the nft errors right
now you can't talk about nfts without
getting people upset but I was gonna
sell a version of the nft that came with
the real scooter and I was gonna sell it
and then build one that was one entire
and then break the record again I I felt
bad about doing it so I decided against
it how did you it looks like there's
different stilts going on here yeah this
is so there's a stilt there that's
actually my buddy built these this is
one of the highest stilts he ever built
so so those are Peg stilts yeah that's a
peg store and like that I mean that's
like legit have you ever been on one
that High I mean dude one time I made
out with a giraffe while walking on like
six foot pics that's nothing those are
nine feet yeah I mean dude like six feet
from the yeah it's hardcore yeah it's
nine foot Peg studs is gnarly I was
actually
um I bought a smart car to do a bunch of
dumb stunts with and um I wanted to uh
one of them to be
like six foot pegs to the the smart cars
uh hair over five feet tall so I figured
if I was wearing six foot wooden Peg
stilts the car could blow out the stilts
and I would just go to the ground but uh
man maybe maybe I should revisit that
idea instead I could connect you with my
friend
no it's not Randy my friend who builds
stilts it's Larry Linguini
how high are you comfortable with still
it's like what's the highest when I was
when I was making out with the giraffe I
would I was uh like I'm six feet and
then the still turns six feet so that
made me 12 feet tall yeah uh Dura stilts
are typically four feet tall like fully
extended so I was running two feet more
than fully extended tourists I don't
know I would do like maybe six foot
seven foot I could connect you with this
guy in L.A yeah no Santa Fe
Santa Fe New Mexico yeah but he can ship
them all right I got it I got to make a
move pretty quick and uh pegs Stills
aren't that complicated no it's not but
the thing is rigging it up with this was
it was incredibly that's why there was a
lot of engineering that went into home
yeah you don't want to fall over I know
no it's serious danger and what about
your pants the pants can get caught in
the wheel too so you have to be very
careful but yeah I had various versions
so that if you look at like uh one of
the ones where I'm not on the stilts you
can still ride it
um there's a miniature handlebar that's
lower so I actually had to set up so
that I could practically ride it and
then I have one that's set up when I
could ride it with stilts but that as
you can see I actually crashed it how
did you get that to Russia for your
music video oh I didn't that was a
separate scooter so that was my first
attempt and that wasn't Russia that was
in Ukraine Ukraine so it was my first
attempt to build the world's biggest
scooter and I had my first big budget I
mean my second one I guess but this one
was a really large scale music video
budget I had over a million dollars to
make this I I had trouble believing that
and um my Ukrainian dollars no that's
USD we looked it up and it's on it's
it's just Wikipedia it's listed as the
number 34. yeah we were 33 for a while
someone knocked us out yeah the most
expensive music videos ever so then I
asked my guy uh Isaac to
um where's Thriller was on the list
right Thrillers in the 70s I know 70s
or no seven oh seven number one was
Michael Jackson and Janet Jackson that
one is a nightmare have you seen it uh
it's called scream it's like the early
days of VFX but I think it was like all
the money went into this VFX for a
airplane or something but it's like so
horrible it did not age at all but they
spent some I think those numbers are
[Music]
but if you look at like the actual
products I think people are just
pocketing most of that money because the
quality is so so low well yeah they're
probably paying Michael Jackson
75 of them you think so or you think
that there's like the Purdue I feel like
it's always the producers I mean why
they're pocketing the cash
of that's my experience
I don't know what to say about that
sometimes people get taken advantage of
but what really sucks is when people are
taking advantage of themselves
you know like letting a nasty habit just
hold you back compromise your health
ruin your life now now I'm not having it
I'm not having it and that's why this
episode is sponsored by fume yeah what's
fam it's a device okay it's a device
that helps you quit nasty habits I mean
you can trade in breathing in Crazy
chemicals with just breathing fresh air
what's so special about it is that it's
flavored air because you've got a core
in your fume device and that core
flavors air man now like hey I think we
all know I
quit my main bad habits over 15 years
ago I still love this thing I even made
a deal with you guys that if you see me
in person ask me if I've got my fume in
my pocket because I will man I don't go
anywhere without it I love this thing
and if I don't have it in my pocket when
you ask me well then I'll make whatever
little Shout Out video you want me to
make on your cell phone that offer is
good with every listener of the Wild
Ride podcast for the rest of this
calendar year yeah dude that's how much
I love fume and that's how much I want
you to drop your nasty habit and replace
it with the good one so go to
tryfume.com and use the promo code Stevo
to get 10 off your journey pack why is
it called a journey pack because your
journey starts now baby it starts now
it's a journey towards being a better
you and a you that you feel good about
so try fume.com use the promo code Steve
for 10 off your journey pack now let's
get back to it yeah where do you make
your money back on a music video just by
yourself yeah I don't think an artist
makes any money you don't make any money
on music I mean you get an advance but
now you do on YouTube or Vimeo right the
label takes all of it but they give you
an advance of like okay your next album
here's the money and you kind of survive
off of advances from the recording side
but you don't make a penny on any of it
well I mean you gotta figure that it's
basically promotion yeah it was an
artist it's promotion figure tour did
you tour yeah I'm actually about to go
on a world tour so Paris Luxembourg yeah
hit an Australia New Zealand uh yeah I'm
gonna do most of Europe and then the UK
so I gotta believe that your live show
is gonna have like some elements I've
just invested so much money into it I
basically made my live show into a
mixture of a movie and a play and
um somewhere between like a TV show and
a concert and so for me that the new
version of the show I'm so excited but
then it's like you know you're always
like oh next time I return to this place
and it's probably different as a
comedian I know you guys have much less
overhead so you can actually like make
your money but on in music like the team
gets Biggers and I have to fly 15 people
around the world and then I have to
bring these massive LED screens and I'm
trying to bring these pieces for
production and the other artists that
you're trying to bring on you got to
support them and it's like it becomes
this thing where every time I'm like oh
next time I'll make my money back and
then I'm always just like oh but the
show gets crazier and I want to deliver
I don't want to do the half-assed
version but I did the first show at Red
Rocks
um about like two months ago and yes
that was like the First dress rehearsal
we had never even got through an entire
version of the set and that was our full
dress rehearsal and it was insane to see
it come to life and there's like little
literally I have these cues in my ear
they're called slates and I have like
maybe a hundred of them in my ear it's
like turn left turn right all these
things while I'm singing I'm listening
to these things adjusting so that I'm in
motion with the visuals behind me but
it's like it's performance art but
mixing together like my love for
filmmaking as a director and producer
and and I wrote a 34-page screenplay for
it so it's like Fusion you know and I
know that that's something you do really
well is Fusion after like both of us
have been able to mix our careers by
just pulling from so much stuff that's
something I've always admired from you
and I think you've done excellently it's
it's created such a unique Avenue for
you and not just you know with jackass
but wild boys and so many other things
so it's been you've been a tremendous
inspiration for me thanks man I uh I
definitely relate to the idea of uh
bringing different
Lanes together you know like that's
that's a big thing for me man think
about this there's not that much room to
do anything new if you think that you've
invented the wheel again you haven't no
matter what you're like oh my God I just
come with this idea and you've done a
lot of stuff for the first time you know
I've seen even just coming down to the
way you promote things different things
like that you're like a guy who's always
like coming up with new fresh things
that haven't been done yet but in a lot
of ways there's probably a micro version
of it that has been done somewhere else
or something you you think oh I just
came up with this crazy idea but it's
like six other people have either had
the idea and probably at least one of
them is executed upon it just might be a
smaller scale or a different variation
so for me it's like the only room for
Creative breakthroughs and new territory
is when you fuse together mediums it's
like for me in music like my last album
was a country album then I put out my
next song was like dance music and the
album before that was alternative rock
music and pop music and Hip-Hop and so
it's like there's not a lot of room to
make a new song you know there's only so
many chord progressions there's only so
many popcorn progress questions so then
it Narrows even more and then there's
only so many lyrics in English that
really are like fit into the rhyme
scheme patterns and you're such there's
such limitations so for me as an artist
I'm like well what do I do to make this
interesting I'm like okay well I could
do Fusion like the gorillas was a big
inspiration for me it's like how do I
mix together all these genres that don't
belong together but then it's like at a
certain way like that's a little bit
boring too even that seems like it's
already all been done and so then it's
like okay how can I mix the mediums
together how can I bring in like really
focus on filmmaking and do it in a way
with music that is like feels fresh and
try to bring new ideas but you know no
matter what I'm like shit's already
played out as far as like the music
videos go and filmmaking who are your
Inspirations growing up because when I
watch your music videos I I get a lot of
like uh like old Missy Elliot Vibe and
like I believe his name was Dave Mayers
who directed all of like her Busta
Rhymes videos because all your videos
are so bright everything's outrageous
huge so like who are your Inspirations
for me it was more of a feature
filmmaker or so like Wes Anderson the
Symmetry on him is something I've taken
a lot from in some of the color palettes
um Tarantino with some of the you know
explosions and violence a little bit but
I have to keep it you know it's crazy
because we have freedom of speech but
there's so much limitations you know
before I come in you're like hey don't
swear for the beginning it's like yeah
and you're the craziest dude you know
like I don't even want to begin to say
some of the stuff you've done but it's
like you know what I mean it's like but
you have to limit yourself and there's
nothing wrong with that and as I've
tried to expand as an artist it's like
how do I reach a bigger audience how do
I reach you know make it so that little
kids can watch it too I don't want to
just make it only for this a niche adult
audience or people who are like you know
it's like in between the age 20 and 35
or something like that you don't want to
narrow yourself so you have to play and
abide by these rules because you do want
it to be like accessible but also you're
like okay well now I have to slip on a
banana instead of the person pushing me
off of the top of the bus and this bus
sequence fight I did for my last video
and it's like
pocket you know what I mean well what
was your bus sequence
um well I was riding a pogo stick doing
pogo stick flips and that actually took
a long time to learn how to pogo
stick have you ever pogoed
um
not really and and that's why I wouldn't
like this one four months yeah the ones
that they're doing these days you can
see on the tick tock the first left one
yeah Pogo these days it's crazy so
gnarly it's got to be so dangerous yeah
I think basically it might just show a
little Montage this isn't the actual
music video but just like a clip from um
not sure but
anyway this is actually you doing the
flip I do all my own stunts there's no
stand-ins
this is a guy who's not me but basically
like you know I do the sequence where
I'm these yellow guys are chasing I mean
this is a horrible way to see it because
it's all cropped in from uh you know I
went up on the rooftop of the buses and
you could stop it there but it's like a
whole fight sequence that takes place
and um you know shooting instead of me
shooting like I wanted to have
potentially like the idea of like a gun
that shoots out of the pogo stick but
I'm like that's way too gnarly like I
don't want to be supporting in the
school shooter thing it's like you have
to be very conscious of what you're
putting out but I was like okay well a
fun silly way is that like it shoots a
little rocket and the rocket explosion
is like this tall and the guys jump out
you know what I mean like kind of
finding ways to make it like fun and for
all ages and not like feeding into
something that might be a negative thing
you have to watch because you don't even
realize it's like the potential of what
something someone could get out of
something you know right do you have uh
like
different uh art that is designed to be
like not careful like crazy Reckless not
allowed on YouTube I don't know I do
make a lot of stuff and then I have to
shove a lot of it so I have like crazy
stuff that I've done and then I'm like
well is that our Willies I yeah I was
gonna ask you guys about that so I saw
you guys went to my boy R Willy's house
in Australia how was that experience
I just knew before going there that I
wasn't going to want to jump off the the
ramp and uh I think Ryan didn't quite
understand that
well for him it's like drinking a glass
of water right right yeah right I know I
mean this is a real Daredevil in the
crazy right here so I'm surprised I mean
I was surprised that I did it but I saw
his mom do it yeah then I saw Isaac do
it and I was like you just hold on right
I just have so much experience with
getting broken before I even make it off
a ramp and you had a tour still going on
correct yeah that was right before Gold
Coast that's the dangerous size like the
middle of the tour I think right yeah so
do you have a background in BMX or
anything are you just well I mean that
thing was just so easy you just I mean I
closed my eyes before I went off the
ramp because I didn't you know I love it
but but yeah the thing with action
sports to me is like we're talking about
art to me this is the greatest art form
and like when I see someone one like our
Willy
I mean I think he's the greatest artist
of Our Generation this dude is willing
to die for his self-expression truly die
like it happens often it's not a nor
it's not a thing that's like oh my God
you couldn't be more right about that
and I uh I mean if you're off inches you
break a collarbone or whatever
he
um absolutely does things that have
never been done on a regular basis like
when you're talking about everything
that's multiple different things too
right scooter BMX well that's the thing
now he's kind of moved more into the BMX
Lane because like me and him grew up
scootering and when you learn how to
flip on a scooter the rotation is faster
because it has a lower center of gravity
compared to a BMX so he learned how to
spin a BMX bike better than the BMXers
based on his knowledge of scooter and
his knowledge of how the gravity Works
um and how he can get faster spins so
like him being a scooter rider was the
ultimate Advantage for him to break into
the BMX world but now he's pretty much
taking the whole BMX World by storm it's
like such inspiration I was with him I
actually competed against him at our
Willy land and I creamed him dude I
actually beat the guy really
because he's been more focused on BMX so
his his scootering is Rusty but we we
basically left it as like a standstill
and our Willy if you're watching this
when you're ready you come to Oliver
Tree Town back in Santa Cruz come jump
on my 25 foot ramp at my parents
house let's finish this like a
man yeah what happened to the footage of
you creaming him oh it's on there this
is the video I competed against the
number one scooter rider in the world I
beat him it's on YouTube learning
learning how to to scooter in Santa Cruz
I feel like it'd be hard to go to a
skate park in Santa Cruz with a scooter
that's true well there was bike parks
and um I grew up biking as well biking
was a huge part of it for me so like I
raced BMX downhill
um did everything from four cross to the
solemns
um cross country cycle cross we lift the
bike on your shoulder like I did every
type of bike racing you can uh
but
jumping was what I did for fun and like
scootering is inter trying with that my
dad he had a huge love for biking he
would be like the coach of the um high
school he built like he made a uh cross
country team there and then he was one
night he came home he's like
he's like Oliver come with me and me and
my brother went with him and he's like
he took me to this place he's like yo
I'm gonna build a bike park right here I
was like Dad you're crazy what are you
talking about but basically there was a
spot called the Fun Spot as a skate um
thing that was getting torn down and
they were going to build a different
skate park that was like millions and
millions of dollars of infrastructure
and my dad was like well we could use
the old ramps from the Fun Spot and
build a legit legal bike park so the
bikers have a place to go so he like was
able to facilitate in getting the
company that he worked for at the time
to help kind of invest some money into
building the first legit Bike Park in
Santa Cruz so you could scooter there
and then that one at a certain plan to
get moved and he me and all my friends
and stuff his company like helped pay us
to work and rebuild the next bike park
but uh it's called the Fun Spot was the
original the first one but then it
turned it was a skate park and it turned
into a bike park but yeah it's evolved
again the newer version is slightly
shifted and then it was the post office
oh that's the Polar grounds I used to
hit all these spots but there was a huge
mountain bike scene in Santa Cruz and I
grew up in that scene and my dad's the
company he worked for they were
rebuilding these buildings and there was
on this famous legendary if you look up
the post office that's where like I used
to go when I was it's an Aptos and
basically the post office was the center
of like the whole West Coast dirt bike
jumping scene and uh that's it right
there and then basically my the company
my dad worked for they were gonna tear
them down because they're building these
buildings but they weren't going to
build them for years and there was like
a security it was an issue with just
getting sued basically and my dad was
like able to keep it alive and so he was
like an advocate of always trying to
like make a safe place for bikers
because the skate park you're not it's
not cool to ride a bike and it's
definitely not cool to ride a scooter
there so this has been a big part of my
like background in getting into stunts
and doing for me like this was kind of
my real addiction you know growing up
before I got into heavy drug use and not
at that point in pendulums you know yeah
I uh I I heard that you um
got kicked out of your house for being a
drug addict when you were in high school
I used to sell drugs as well that was
the real reason oh my God that's the
hardest I laughed when uh
was so hysterically funny well it's
because I didn't say it my friend get
her one of the settings it was his voice
okay but yeah it was crazy out that
whole thing with that that was the first
time I ever dressed like that and that
was like the original character and that
was a joke by the way but he was kidding
you know
[Laughter]
yeah there it is
but yeah that was the thing where I
showed up to a music video shoot I had
my first chance to be in a music video
that would reach MTV well I don't know
if it was mtv2 at the time or whatever
it was but I was like okay how do I want
to present myself do I want to sell sex
and like try to be like everyone else or
do I want to try to make myself look as
ugly as possible so that I can stand out
and be stick out like a sore thumb
amongst all these other people selling
sex so for me it was like the first
thing so I was like what can I do and I
just pulled things from my youth you
know the bull cut was the haircut I had
my whole life growing up I was too
scared to get any other haircut the ski
jacket I stole from my mom
um the glasses were like the glasses I
wear as a kid that made me feel cool the
jinko jeans were like the pants that I
always wanted and the socks and sandals
combo was like the most goony ridiculous
style of Footwear I would wear so it was
pulled together very like you know
authentic to me like I didn't have to
buy the jacket I literally stole it from
my mom's closet and I have pictures of
my parents wearing that my dad wore it
sometimes skiing and my mom would wear
it so it's like a family Relic at this
point but anyways I pulled all that
together and I show up to the music
video shoot and my friend getter who is
one of the studs he like looks right
through me he didn't even recognize me
and I had gone like spent time out he
showed me how to produce a lot of uh my
beginning era was like formative years
he showed me how to produce and I showed
him how to DJ and he became a very
successful DJ so it was crazy we both
showed each other so much but he I'd
known him for like six years spent so
much time in high school with him and he
like looked right to me he didn't even
know it was me and then he was like no
way we gotta go film some Vines it was
like back in the vine era and we filmed
these three Vines and this is after I
had already gone through like failed
record career failed like so much stuff
that I've tried so hard to be a serious
artist and then we feel and no one
listens to my music no one cared and
like then we filmed these Vines and the
first one got posted this one and it got
like maybe one or two million in the
first couple days and then like then he
posted another one and it was us dancing
and that one got a million in the first
dared to and then posted another one
that one got a million and I was like
what the hell is going on here I spent
my whole life making art nobody cares
and somehow now I've figured out that
this I didn't even have to try I just
show up looking silly and that's what
people want to see they didn't even care
so I was like so then that just sort of
like informed a new approach to
everything that you tried before and all
of a sudden it started working it was
fairly calculated because I had the
strategy I'm gonna go in this is what I
want to wear but that was also playing a
cashier in this video and like they're
like you can't wear the jacket you can't
wear this like it doesn't fit the story
and I was like all right that's fine but
anyways I just saw I was like that was
the original plan look that I wanted to
do and I was like this really worked too
well I was like how is this way more
potent than the art I've been making so
I was like how do I find a way to use
this look and really like maximize on it
to use it as a vehicle to pull all these
people over to my music and that first I
kind of was like weary I was like I
don't really want to like make it Force
promotion of the songs so I just kind of
developed the persona and kind of
developed trying to make it so that this
character could kind of live in the
internet and not necessarily make it
like this guy's a musician so people
were like no this guy makes music but I
was like no it's the other way around I
always made music no one just cared
about it and no one gave a so I was
like I was able to kind of like slowly
ease in and I have this idea and I think
you've executed this very well but it's
like when you are
um someone who really loves to do
something and you have built an audience
you could shift the audience to
something else like if I wanted to be
the world's greatest Chef I could be
like hey guys I've actually always been
a chef and follow along with me on this
journey and if you make it as authentic
as you can they're there for you
obviously they want to see a certain
thing like they want to see your stunts
but that doesn't mean they don't want to
see you do your comedy specials or the
different things obviously there's a
crossover and you have these van
diagrams of different levels of like
okay this audience likes the stunts this
audience likes the comedy this audience
likes and there's like you know maybe 20
of them for someone like you and myself
as well where you have the super fans is
where they all interlap in the center
you know there's like the Super Fan and
then there's people across the board who
are all kind of it's not like they're
just gonna like one thing they'll
probably be able to cross into other
ones they might be like Stevo's comedy
is trash I'm not gonna listen to that
but everything else they love or they're
like just call me so funny I don't
really want to see them naked though you
know what I mean and it's I experience
that all the time with what I do well
how did you open for Skrillex because
that was before all that was before all
that yeah so you were somewhere is this
alcohol nope I'm sober so good I love it
man yeah that's not alcohol it's just
water bro it's liquid death I like it oh
what was your question before because
you're successful but you're successful
enough to get the attention of I was a
DubStep DJ back in the day I had many
iterations so like I was in like uh yeah
and she really tied his buddy out of DJ
yo he taught he yeah I did teach him but
he said he'd be successful but like you
got to be somewhat successful if you're
touring around with Skrillex I didn't
tour around with them I played an
opening slot in San Francisco it was
like I signed my first agency was like
this dubstep thing that was happening in
Santa Cruz and um I just kind of worked
my way up to it but it was something
where I only got that because I was
playing like backyard parties and
whatever and there was like a guy who
was a hero to me and then basically like
I basically like showed him what he saw
what I was doing and he was blown away
and he's like you guys need to sign this
dude so it was the kind of thing where
just a lot of hard work and a lot of
trial and error and that came after a
period where I was in heavy duty drug
issues where it was like once I got out
of it and hit my rock bottom and had my
like you know LSD rebirth then I was
like okay I need to like Channel this
energy and this addiction into something
else so it's like the addiction it's
about addiction hopping you know if
you're an addictive personality like you
and I it's not about like oh no I'm
gonna be not addicted it's like okay
like I'm gonna
learn how to be addicted to something
healthier you know and that has to shift
so for me I found that was like music
was basically like my religion saved my
life from like okay now I have an outlet
and I had an opportunity to play at a
Big Show and that show went great and it
led to the next one and that one went
great and then it led to me opening for
Skrillex and then after that I was like
man that went so great what did you guys
think they're like well
we're really looking to push our artists
that are making music and I had always
grown up making music like I was the fat
kid in band the band class playing
baritone in the the back of the room I
was like you know I played piano since I
was a very young kid I wrote like
albums even at the age of four I had
been playing like guitar taking lessons
all through middle school and elementary
school so like I had like my first rock
band I was I joined in was called irony
and it was in Middle School
um and then that like it ended up
turning into it then I was in a rap
group called mind and then after
that then I was a DubStep DJ called
crife and so I had all these different
iterations and these different things
but like you know I hit that that last
era and they were like uh yeah we want
to push you know people who are really
producing I was like all right I make
music I'll focus more on production I
get it so I started making music and I
was like what I was making was not
naturally coming out as dubstep and I
was like I don't really want to force
myself and it was at the time where the
drugs started wearing off and you start
getting sober and you're like is this
really something I want to contribute to
because when you go to those Raves and
you start seeing those kids that are
spun out of their mind they're like
yeah and the Jaws are tweaking and
you're like seeing the same people over
and over and they look like zombies and
I was that you know what I mean so but
you could see it from another lens and
so for me like seeing that I was like
holy like realistically I can't I'm
not gonna force myself to make dubstep
you know and then essentially
I was just making music and it was more
like Indie pop music and bedroom
production it was a mixture of hip-hop
and like uh alternative pop music and
then it was just one of those things
where it was like okay I'm not gonna
force myself and I kind of saw early on
I was like how far can this whole like
Drop thing go and these different things
so I kind of was turned off at a certain
point I was like there's so much like
restrictions with the genre like a
building a drop it's like okay like
that's kind of boring for me I'd love to
like make songs and so I shifted and I
did the right thing but it was very
painful because I had to start back over
again and that whole thing was put to
the side and so it's just you know
different iterations but ironically
enough
now I've been focused making my first
return to DJing and so I played a hard
summer this weekend with uh Dylan
Francis and also I sang some songs but
actually DJ that kicked him off the DJ
booth and showed him how it was done I
played some stuff with some other
artists as well but I did my own set on
the day after but I'm kind of
re-emerging myself into it and I've
spent 400 hours working on my my return
as a DJ so I'm putting this show
together Dr Oliver tree dubstep DJ so
I'm returning my dubstep debut is that
something did you have a DJ portion of
your show at Red Rocks no ah no I did
not but there was DJ who opened up for
me supercomputer this new act that I
just recently signed to my label alien
Boy Records so super computer played
right before me that's DJ project and
then Little Ricky as well those are the
two acts that I signed to my record
label but anyways that's the same thing
what are you gonna say I'm sorry for
interrupting him normally I'm getting
better at night no I'm just ranting at
this time I'm good
um I'm just apologizing to my list well
I'm sorry as well your listeners having
to hear me talk they want to hear
Stephen no no no no no you're doing
great man this is fantastic and we're
loving it
um I just want really want to know is
this is uh is your upcoming tour does it
make sense for you to add in a little
little dj performance I mean I would
love to do that there's a world where
there may be after parties or different
things but I'm just trying to take it to
such a high level like 400 hours is a
lot to spend on DJ said it's not even
completely finished but I'm mastering it
and I need to now spend a shitload of
money to make crazy visuals and I really
want I want to like as an artist it's
not about oh yeah like DJing could save
me money or DJ I'm like I see the
potential from an artistic standpoint
how could I contribute to make the
craziest DJ show ever made you know what
I mean every time I try to take on
something I'm like how do I make it the
craziest thing it's ever been done and
it always falls so short and I look out
like it looks like like but you
know whatever the intentions there and
and I I uh bring that up like
incorporating that into the show because
um Kid Rock
such a ridiculously talented human being
like I I saw him at his show on his tour
and he goes around the stage plays the
drums he plays the guitar like he plays
like like weird instruments like uh I
don't know if you played a cello you
know like you just can play everything
and he's unbelievably talented on it
then after the show he'll go to like the
club and like take over the DJ booth and
then now like he's the most like
mesmerizing DJ like he just does it all
and so
um you know when you talk about your
show being something that really brings
all the different things that you do I
mean I don't know I wouldn't want you to
half-ass it by doing like uh you know an
underwhelming like short DJ thing but if
you just hopped on and just like really
really gave it to him really hard and
then hopped on some other you know
yeah no for me it's a very separate
thing because the DJ said it's like
it's mixture of all the music that I
grew up loving and then some of my
music's in there but like I don't want
to make I want to make sure that the
audience understands this is a very
separate thing it's not like me just
playing my songs you know what I mean
it's like right right right but anyways
long story short I see them living
separately never together but like for
example I just this weekend I played
this thing Hard Summer or something it's
called in Los Angeles and like for
example next year if I play or two years
later I hope to play one day as a DJ and
one day as my band so the two can kind
of live in conjunction but be separate
because they're very different things so
like I would I would keep the shows
separate it's a lot of work to do the
normal show okay I would give myself at
least a few hours to rest and maybe do
after party or something let me ask you
this when you come out on stage at Red
Rocks are you not hitting it
hard on your scooter oh I always do
scooter stunts that's a signature thing
see that's the thing is that scooters
and what you're doing with your music
are two very separate things but you put
them together 100 that's like that
chocolate and peanut butter so if
you rode your scooter off in DJ
booth and then picked up your guitar
like now I'm hard as a rock I like it
I'm getting hard just thinking about it
Mom
I think you might be onto something big
here man I like this I like where your
head's at you Loosely graze the subject
of a life-changing LSD experience yes
that is correct Burning Man family
vacation to burning man what happened
um
I feel compelled to warn you guys right
now that the story Oliver is about to
tell about his life-changing experience
is not necessarily A recommended
approach to improving your life okay I
said it it's probably not healthy now
what is a healthy approach to improving
your life is the sponsor of this episode
it's better help this episode is brought
to you by better help and that is about
finding an appropriate and healthy way
to change your life for the better what
is it it's therapy baby it's a platform
which connects people with licensed
qualified therapists and it takes out
the going to the office the getting in
the car driving across town you do it
all online and they've matched up over 3
million people with licensed qualified
therapists plus when you're on the
website and you're
looking for the therapist you're
plugging in specifically what it is you
want to work on I'll go ahead and tell
you straight up what I go to therapy for
is to work on my relationship with my
fiance because man I strongly believe
it's better to fix the roof before it
rains than to you know what happens if
you don't if you got problems man I
don't want problems in my relationship I
want to have a healthy relationship and
I want it to work great and that's why
therapy is important to me now
everybody's got stuff to work on and
that's what better help is all about
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash TiVo betterhelp.com
Stevo for 10 off your first month jump
on this your life will improve and
you'll be glad you did now let's get
back to it
what was the trip like the trip was
I went to my own funeral I watched my
death play out um yeah basically
I watched my life play out as a drug
addict this was kind of at like my very
very bottom bottom and um how old were
you this was when I was 17 I believe it
was right before my senior year in high
school with the burning man with your
parents at 17. yeah and I was this is
right when I was kind of rekindling my
relationship with them because that
summer I had been kicked out I was doing
different hard drugs every day just
mixing them all together as well and
selling hard drugs to survive and my
friends were cool enough to let me live
at their houses so it wasn't like I was
homeless I had people that took care of
me but like you know it was like very
dark period of my life and um that's the
difference between a homeless person and
a couchsurfer right is charisma
and con Artistry which I think you and I
both have fitted up very well no
Charisma
but yeah basically you know I was in a
very low place and um with that I kind
of I was supposed to meet my parents the
night of the burn so
I've been kind of doing my own thing
seeing like the concerts and stuff on my
own and like the last night was the
night of the burnout I was supposed to
meet with my parents and
um the Playa is super massive and
there's no I don't know how it is now
but when I went there's definitely no
cell phone reception right have you been
no I I
consider that a no-fly zone bro I feel
like that you would have the time of
your life there I mean I know they have
like you know sober communities there
you don't need to be are you in a you
can't be around people that part-tick
it's not that I can't be around it I
just have to like have a legitimate
reason for being there and it's well
it's just like the craziest art
performance of all time I mean people
spend their whole years making these art
vehicles that are like you know pirate
ships driving through we'll go to the
next one it's pretty wild I think that's
perfectly Fair
um my other you have to go dude no I'm
not here to sell you on it I only went
one time it's not like I'm a burner
right my other Prejudice is that I don't
really like being over in in a big crowd
oh I'm right there with you it's a lot
of work but you can wear a disguise bro
yeah oh yeah I mean everybody's in this
people everyone's wearing like things
covering their face from this the dust
so talking about YouTube we went to this
YouTube convention the remember VidCon
and um I was like man walking around to
convince it's gonna be a lot of work
dude I'm gonna like get a disguise you
know and so I went and bought a
stormtrooper costume at the costume
store and I go to the VidCon and
everybody's stopping me to take pictures
with the Stormtroopers you spent too
much money on it dude
now you said you you saw your funeral
like okay like get deeper into that okay
so what happened was anyways I'm
supposed to meet my parents we missed
the Rendezvous spot and basically I
brought acid a bunch there thinking hey
like I'm gonna try to do with my family
and they were my my parents were kind of
open to the idea but it seemed like it
maybe wasn't gonna happen but anyways
like I take this acid and I'm supposed
to meet up with them at this thing but I
didn't have any water and I was like oh
I think I have enough time to go back to
where I was staying and get water and
come back and or no I was like I didn't
have time to meet them back there before
they come here and I went and then they
were gone the people I was with are like
they already left and then they real
that was when it clicked to me I'm like
oh you're not going to be finding your
family because it's just mass chaos the
night of the burn it's always chaos
there but and you're not allowed to
spend money everything's barter yeah
pretty much I mean you could buy coffee
you can buy coffee and ice and water I
thought like as I understood it money is
no good like well you have to pay like a
ton of money to get in there you know I
don't know it's not cheap so but the
idea is really cool concept of like
sharing and
um kind of just like trading but going
back to the story so anyways the whole
thing the trip starts by me missing my
parents which was supposed to be like a
really epic special thing we all went to
Burning Man with the intention to spend
this beautiful night together so I'm
just like start frying off out of my
mind on acid and like I was like I had
taken I had like a bunch of the
strongest assets I've ever gotten I
bought like half a sheet for my friend
and it was double dose to begin with but
then I had taken it to some different
festivals and things were as hot and I I
was like okay there's probably heat
damage this may be and I don't know like
what's the idea behind that that I had
in my mind but it was certainly not and
I was like oh I'll just take extra and
so I took a bunch which was like the
equivalent of probably eight tabs or
something like that and I just I just
fried out of my mind to the point where
like the burning was happening of this
giant man he's like 50 I don't know how
much 100 feet tall some crazy number
he's Giant and they burn this thing it's
like a sacrifice and then I'm just like
in my mind all of a sudden I'm like next
to the BBC there's like real like news
sources documenting and I'm like oh I'm
here to give a speech like in my mind I
thought I was and I'm like giving the
speech about how incredible burning man
is and then all of a sudden there's
cameras everywhere around me like
hundreds of them people are closing in
on me with video cameras and news
reporters and I'm like get the away
from me like I was having open eye
full-on delusional because what I guess
what happened was I got hungry and then
I ate a bunch of weed brownies that my
parents made but the weed brownies were
so strong that normally you would just
pass out your eyes go bloodshot but when
you're on acid you don't fall asleep so
it was like that's probably what pushed
the edge to the next level as well
because like it started getting super
paranoid and I think the weed brownies
was a big part of that and also maybe
taking the hallucinations to another
level because I never had those types of
hallucinations on LSD but maybe I just
never had taken quite enough you know
but it was so crazy so they're closing
in on me I'm like riding this big wheel
chopper bike through the desert I'm like
get the away from me I'm like
cruising down like I don't give a
if I hit anybody like I'm ready to just
plow them down I'm going through and I
start overheating it's essentially like
a PCP type moment I know you used to do
dabble I love that so I started
overheating I'm like oh my God I got it
I rip all my clothes off I'm completely
naked I had a backpack filled with like
ounce and a half of mushrooms I just
throw everything that I had the bike
down I'm just like running and I'm like
I gotta get out of here I gotta get I
think all these like devils and things
are trying to kill me and I'm like start
going into this like dark reality where
I'm basically
I at some point like collapsed and I see
my eyes are playing movies they're open
but I'm just watching movies and it
shows my naked body on the front page of
the newspaper and it's like boy
overdoses at Burning Man and then I'm
transported to my funeral and I hear all
my families there my intermediate Aunts
Uncles cousins grandma and parents and
whatever and everyone's just weeping
like he was such a good kid but he did
so much drugs so I essentially had
watched my life play out as a drug
addict like there was a moment before
that where I was running and I went from
like this light around me that like
because that day or the day before I
found out I was gonna play my first big
DJ event so I feel like there was this
like light that was around me and I was
like ran further and further out into
the desert the light disappeared and I
was just in darkness all alone as and I
watched myself age from my childhood to
an old weathered out old Skeleton Man
and then at that point I died that was
this whole thing I watched my life play
out as an addict and then basically I
was so high I couldn't even see I was
just watching movies I'm running through
the desert and there's the outside
parameter fence which is a snow fence I
couldn't even see it I was so
high hallucinating these things that I
flip over my body's cut covered in but
like cuts on my dick I'm sure you know
how that is with some of your stunts
um especially the ball sack stapling
yeah I I've been there man I keep
running though I'm like I gotta get the
out of here this is hell like I'm
trapped in this never-ending Rave hell I
thought I was like there's like all
these Rave things and I would be going
in circles and it was just like I
thought I was paying for my sins as a
raver almost like the rave music was
just never ending and I'm like running
out there trying to escape this hell
realm and I eventually like and I'm just
my body's like I'm trying to rip when I
was on the ground I try to hit my I
think I'm dead right but my body is
still going I don't understand it
exactly but it was almost as if my brain
had been destroyed my body was still
going so I was on the ground
hitting my head against the bottom
desert floor which is incredibly hard
and I was hitting my head pulling on my
hair trying to pull my brain out of my
head and so it was this crazy things on
my head's now warped I'm covering Cuts
I'm running as far as I can my feet are
covered in Cuts because I'm running on
rocks and stuff and a veg at a certain
point I can't down enough I'm like
there's nothing out here I gotta and I
see the light in the distance like miles
out I could have easily died it's like
freezing out there and it's like
probably 2 A.M in the morning and I'm
just like running out there and then I'm
like there's something in the distance I
was like I gotta go to the light and
that was the Burning Man
The Burning Man had already been burnt
but the actual event the the festival is
filled with lights and craziness so I
was running towards that I saw it in the
distance yeah they have like a big
ferris wheel kind of they got everything
you could imagine but yeah I'm saying
like giant rubber ducky disco text you
know it's just like a crazy art scene we
could have this RV there and you've got
to kick it in the RV you could interview
all the people out of their mind on
ketamine yeah but long story short then
I like hopped over this fence because I
could see again and I'm running in and
all of a sudden there's like a ranger
basically they have people guarding the
parameter this was like when I had come
down enough that my mine was melted but
I could still see again and they were
like did you just sneak in I was like
fully naked I was like sneak in from
where like so I like run into the thing
and now I'm like entering into a party
of 60 000 people I'm completely naked
and I don't have my clothes and I'm like
streaking through this party what
happened to the backpack full of
mushrooms lost it all I was thinking
about that
because that mushrooms I used to sell
mushrooms and there are mushrooms that I
was gonna sell to people and then my
parents found them that was part of like
the reason too like that was part of
around that era was like when I got
kicked out and um basically
they gave me the mushrooms back that I
give it away to people that Burning Man
so it was always supposed to be a gift
to the burners but anyways long story
short I come back and I'm like freezing
after hours I'm covered in cuts my
mind's fried out of just completely
useless I couldn't even remember where I
was staying if I wanted to and so I was
just walking around freezing and these
this woman I started like weeping I was
just had hit such a crazy rock bottom
and This Woman's like are you okay I'm
like not really I don't really know
where to go I lost everything I don't
know where I'm staying and she's like oh
come with me and like she took me back
and like her friends were there and they
gave me this giant cloak and then they
gave me like some water and some cookies
they nurtured me it's that's the cool
thing of Burning Man everyone's kind of
looking out for each other you know
there's a lot of like love in the air
and maybe that's not everyone there's a
lot of random people who show up and are
there to frap row party out or whatever
but the core is kind of this like very
loving experience are the people like
bartering sex and I don't think so
but there's definitely orgies and stuff
like that and there's probably like uh
you know six foot nitrous tanks oh
you would be in heaven back hold you
yeah I remember that from being on
Grateful Dead tour yeah Grateful Dead
how old are you uh 20. wow I saw the
dead at the bowl and then when I was
walking out of the bowl there's probably
two blocks worth of nitrous tanks lined
up and then as you get closer to it you
just hear the people on the floor
laughing as you're getting into
Hollywood a while ago this is
I mean I that was like 10 years ago okay
and then I was eating mushrooms there
was it still it was still called the
dead or was it like further or one or
the other it was the dead it wasn't it
wasn't John Mayer yet they call it the
dead dead and Company yeah because I
went even I walked by and I think it was
further or one of the like different
versions of it that there is now and it
was literally just people with uh huge
balloons just in the street right like
they're just like take over Hollywood
there's a there's a group of guys from
Philadelphia they call themselves The
nitrous Mafia yeah I know they just yeah
they just control the whole east coast
and they just follow fish and there's a
reason why they call it hippie crack
yeah for sure because it brings out the
gnarliest I mean there's a lot of money
in a nitrous tank right like you can
make so much money back in the day it
was five bucks for a balloon yeah ice
cold fatties medical grid
I mean outside tank you can get like a 2
000 this guy sounds like he works for
the night
yeah yeah dude but the the nitrous Mobby
on the East Coast like they're no joke
though like people would end up dead and
like for like bringing their own tanks
to festivals and that's crazy yeah
that's super hard I got Isaac's on point
inside the 19 East Coast hippie crack
ring yeah well it's so addicting too
like while you're doing it you just need
more you calm down and you're like crazy
load me up it's really really crazy and
when you're on other drugs to it yeah
like it's such high level like these
dudes would like because the security
would be so tight to bring stuff into
the festivals that that there was this
uh one called the Gathering of the Vibes
in Bridgeport Connecticut and they would
take uh scuba gear and scuba and they
would scuba these nitrous tanks from
boats like nights before the festival
and go dig them up so like the tanks
will already be on the on the grounds
for when they get there yeah I mean dude
there's high level stuff to get nitrous
or like a medical grade nitrous for sure
yeah or you gotta just have a good
hookup with a dentist I mean I don't
even know I don't even know yeah well
it's crazy that they sell it to kids you
know like when I was in high school they
would let me go in and not tanks but
they would let you buy the ones for
coffee yeah cartridges yeah coffee yeah
what's the what's the reasoning because
they were selling a cracker for the
balloon and they would sell it to me I
was like 15 or 16 times like yeah you
can have that I was like there's no like
you can't buy cigarettes but you can buy
whippets right I I uh were you talking
about buying those at a smoke shop
smokes wow I think you're supposed to be
18 to go into a smoke shop aren't you
well
I grew up in Santa Cruz things maybe a
little different yeah yeah yeah dude
man
um when's your tour start
um
at the end of next month so I think it
really starts in October and November
um it is
something that I've been working on for
literally five years like this show I've
probably invested
four to five million dollars into this
concert so and that sounds like a large
amount but with all the music videos and
things that are in it
um I should say it's well over that dude
I I get that easy I've spent way more
than a million bucks on my uh bucket
list show yeah and I saw you promoted
that recently with jumping off of the
London Bridge yeah yeah bro that is
genius level marketing I think that I'll
just say this I don't think you get
enough credit for being arguably the
greatest marketer of our time oh I don't
know about it the billboard is pretty
funny one of the greatest ever I mean
everybody was like yeah because that was
when the citizen app was popping and it
just went Bonkers on citizen I
appreciate that man do people say this
to you often they must I I've gotten
some some credit this one really worked
out pretty well I was up there with one
of the greatest marketing stunts ever
done yeah they weren't too happy yeah
well well thank you man no and that's
the thing you know when I think about
and also that you're just so shamelessly
self plugging your things but with the
greatest names and it's funny and it's
entertaining and I'm sure probably right
about now you're about to turn into the
camera and turn away at your house
[Laughter]
what can I say Oliver tree knows about
this podcast and knowledge is power
that's why I use whoop man because I
want knowledge about what's going on
with my body with my health with my
sleep with my recovery and there is no
way to get more knowledge about your
body and your Fitness than with whoop
and man I've got the killer new stylish
whoop band I mean dude come on
everything about this company is awesome
and it motivates me to stay on track to
be
getting the exercise keep track of the
activities the calories and most
importantly the sleep I don't know if
you realize how important sleep is but
when you get your whoop then you're
gonna find out a lot about what's going
on it's going to tell you how much sleep
you need it's going to tell you how much
sleep you got I mean I could go on and
on and on and on but what's important
here is you go to whoop.com that's
w-h-o-oop.com and you use the promo code
Stevo to get 10 off at checkout now
you're gonna get the whoop band with the
waterproof charger totally for free and
you're gonna get 10 off the membership
and man I just can't recommend it enough
so one more time go to whoop.com use the
promo code Stevo and change your life
for the better now let's get back to it
cool well I was gonna say so I've been
like trying to promote a bunch of
different stuff and I actually wanted to
see what maybe Stevo would give her
advice from a marketing standpoint so I
have someone here who's going to bring
some of my new products and I wanted to
run them by you I love it and see if you
have any ideas so the first question I
have for you is
do you ever grow facial hair I've never
really seen you with any kind of beard
or anything can you grow it I have okay
pull up Stevo with the mustache Stephen
with a mustache I I grew out a mustache
simply for the purposes of having it
waxed off because I've never seen
somebody wax off and how painful was
that it it was uh it was yeah bring in
the first product so wait actually hold
hold up right there can we bring him in
yeah
not the book
is this okay so basically
see that's I hate to be the guy to say
it but
I can see why you don't grow facial hair
you're not you know it's not very thick
and Lush and dense and I've been
developing this product and over the
last few years I've spent a lot of time
trying to perfect it and now we've got
it down to just one capsule but this is
called go tea grow and this is something
I want to give to you it's it's a gift
for me to you and I was just wondering
how would you promote gotigo do you have
an idea I would just love to hear some
of your ideas you don't have to spend
much time but I was just curious if
something comes to mind I want to do a
quick run through of how Stevo would
promote some of these products
um I think the first thing that my head
goes to is uh
sex cells I like it something sex though
so you want to have like a way of
uh
uh linking having a goatee to just being
an absolute Beaver magnet I love it okay
so you got like uh now I have goats at
my house they have like really like a
couple of one-on-one in particular has
like just the craziest goatee
I would probably start with uh my goatee
can you say it and look into the camera
well I would I would start with my goat
and you'd say my name's Stevo and oh
yeah is it like you hold this yeah I'll
reveal it yeah yeah
hey everybody
hey everybody I'm Stevo and I'm here to
tell you that nothing gets more beef
than a solid goatee now I don't have one
why because I haven't been taking
gotigro
but now that I have goatee grow get
ready to see me smothered in vagina
that was pretty on point all right it
feels good so if you want I would
suggest maybe you try taking your first
one here all right let's see what it's
super high in nutrients it's not gonna
it's nothing bad you can maybe take a
few you might need more than one but we
you know it's not
it's not fully approved yet but we have
it down to it's safe don't worry
all right well
it's been a long time since I took a
pill that I didn't know what it was but
some guy
he's so sketchy dude I'm just talking
about burning man yeah
did you get those at Burning Man
no I made them
I worked with the team you're a legend
bro down the hatch dude hopefully uh
we'll see how you feel in about 20
minutes
okay so the next thing so I understand
you are a New York Times bestseller is
this correct is it more than once or
just one time just one only one so come
on a guy with you in your marketing
skills you've written a few books though
right or someone else writes it you put
your name on it wait wait wait I have
two books and um I collaborated okay
both of them with the same guy so I know
you're a professional New York Times
bestseller but I have a book I have been
writing for the last 18 months and it is
the ancient art of goatee growing and
this is something that I am super proud
of it's something that's I'm actually
unveiling it for the first time right
here on the Wild Ride show with Steve
all right so I think first of all if you
can't
um we can take a glance are you tired of
the same old clean-shaven look frankly
yes I've I've worn it out do you long
for a stylish and sophisticated
facial hairstyle that will set you apart
from the crowd look no further than the
ancient art of goatee growing this
comprehensive guide takes you on a
journey through the history and
evolution of the goatee from its origins
in ancient Greece to its modern day
popularity with step-by-step
instructions and expert advice you'll
learn everything you need to know about
growing and maintaining a perfect goatee
so yeah you don't have to read any more
of that but look in the inside if you
could just read the thesis really quick
and just I think it should be the first
yeah a man without a goatee is like a
lion without a Mane after nearly four
billion years of goatees on planet Earth
there's no reason you shouldn't be able
to grow one for the last five years Dr
Oliver McNichol has worked with a team
of scientists in Morocco perfecting the
perfect goatee formula with only one
pill a day now there's nothing stopping
you from having the best goatee in your
neighborhood go to
gottegrow.com thank you and that is
officially live so you can go and get
your first helping go-to grow
so if you were to promote this book how
did you get your New York Times
bestseller and what would I do what
suggestion do you have for me to try to
sell my book to get a New York Times
bestseller for the ancient art of go-to
guy
um I do a rap song I think music
do a rap song about goatee's that's good
have a good viral on Tick Tock well in
my concert I actually have a little
snippet I'm not supposed to talk about
this but I actually got Eminem to rap a
little bit about goatee and endorse
goatee Grill nice so maybe with just you
know a little sign of a piece of
paperwork we'll put you into the
commercial as well hey dude I'm in okay
that was an easy sell uh can you say
that in the camera I'm in okay cool dude
um and then okay so
I'm just thinking like I've also worked
on this other book and this one I spent
a few years working on and it's a
graphic novel it's called alien boys can
we bring in can we get my guy to bring
it in
so yep so this book I signed the inside
gave you a little bit this one and I
know it's not a New York Times
bestseller yet but this did get a Nobel
Prize nice so no ball or Nobel a noble
piece rise yeah
I like this is something that I wrote
with my friend Orpheus
thank you for being an inspiration to me
since childhood I've looked up to a guy
who covered himself in you make the
world a more colorful place I'm proud of
you for being sober and being an amazing
role model never forget that you are a
Pioneer who has trailblazed their own
wave thank you for existing at the same
time as me sincerely Oliver tree I love
it dude thank you I really really love
it now I heard speculation that Oliver
tree and little Ricky are the same
person oh no no he's a childhood friend
someone I grew up with so he's the first
signing to my record label alien Boy
records and I recently just signed
this new group super computer so those
are kind of my two focused things that
I'm doing outside of my own project
um but yeah this this kind of ties in
the whole world of all the music videos
and builds the universe and I know
you're probably would you do you read do
you know how to I I do know how to read
um I think I've taken a turn
towards audiobooks I love that you grew
up with him Little Ricky yeah that's
yeah he doesn't really look like that
though does he I don't really I can't
say too much but yeah he's a super sweet
guy and um the music that he's making is
insane so it's been pretty epic
getting a chance to see and help him
develop as an artist
um and yeah there's been some kind of
delays and things that have held back
his debut mixtape but we've been working
on it for a few years and it's I'm
really proud of it he was featured on my
first album so it's been pretty epic
anyways okay moving forward
can't plug Little Ricky too much because
this is really about me right and I've
got to promote something else so I have
this new line of merchandise I've been
working on really really long time now
and it's a new
the whole collection is called best
friends and um can we get my guy to
bring and I have a gift for you this is
for you to keep all these is for you to
keep as well so okay nice your guy looks
like you oh yeah that's terrible he's
one of our unpaid interns he gets
college credit
um
so College
what what college is he getting
um I think he goes to in the tri-state
area I don't know the name of it
so this is one of our First Merch pieces
so I think that's pretty sick you want
to show can you show the camera I sure
can
look at Jay Leno and
over a tree would you mind wearing it I
don't mind at all I'd be honored I'd
Rock the out of that yeah dude
where can they get that they can get
that at
olivertreymusic.com I'm selling it
exclusively on my merch store
yeah it is time
oh look at you my dude was straight
boiling I know I've been waiting for
that for a while
all right dude
I'm gonna learn in this we are wearing
matching t-shirts with images of us
and it's kind of the mashup of uh me and
Jay Leno are you mashed up with somebody
or we're both matched up with Jay Leno
both of us
you know I've got Jay Leonard's
autograph tattooed on me no way yeah
straight up and you also have a picture
of yourself tattooed on you yeah is it
over here Jay Lau he really went in on
that one can you show the camera that is
quite impressive he really he spent a
lot of time on that one I yeah I was um
on the The Tonight Show with my buddy
Chris Pontius and it was just a little
gag uh we got Jay Leonard to autograph
my shoulder blade then we went into
commercial by the time we came out of
commercial Pontius had
fully tattooed it wow and I saw that you
also have that other tattoo was it from
Thailand from Wildwood yeah legendary
they just did whatever I know you're
trying to get the Angelina Jolie
um I got them I wasn't sure if it was
real I got the legit Angelina Jolie
tattoo and Chris wasn't so lucky yeah
Chris just got whatever is it the same
guy so funny dude because he Chris made
MTV pay to get his tattoo lasered off oh
damn and we were just talking about that
the other day and I was like man that's
just too funny considering the garbage
that you have tattooed on yourself Chris
the fact that you cared enough to get
something lasered off is really
impressive why did he want that lasered
off because he because it wasn't his
choice
the oldest tattoo trick in the book guy
asks for one tattoo he'd give him
another
I hate it when that happens yeah but uh
that's a legendary one okay so my next
question okay what are you drinking in
this this is coffee man you drink coffee
a lot I drink a lot of coffee I thought
you were sober
okay I'm serious yeah
um a lot of people do carve out caffeine
so you do you smoke cigarettes uh I'm
I'm uh what do you call it
I don't smoke weed I don't smoke
cigarettes cool great for you so I love
that you drink coffee because I have
another thing that I'm selling and I
wanna can we bring in
um our next gift so I wanted to see uh I
think you're really gonna like this by
the way
okay fly that over so this is an
official best friends piece
wow dude that's something that maybe you
can even drink it on the podcast I don't
know I am hyped on this yeah and that's
you know a celebration of your sobriety
how far you've come in now you're down
to just coffee yeah I'm down to just
coffee check that out
actually can you hold that up yeah
yeah wow I've heard it both ways
so that's you and me melted into one
person yeah so I was gonna ask epic yeah
how would you how would you provide this
is my new favorite mug I'm honored I put
a lot of thought into this this was not
something that just happened over here
yeah evidently I mean this is how long
does it take to get a mug like this
months
so if you were to promote the shirt and
the mug I mean we could talk separately
or together as a package what would you
do to promote it is there anything that
comes to mind
I mean
don't Mash your dicks together Mash your
face together here's what uh here here's
what we've come to learn about selling
T-shirts
um the
most effective way is to do it by
pre-order where you make a video right
you make the announcement you say that
this t-shirt will only be available for
one week and you lie to them right no no
we tell the truth one week and it'll
never be available again okay so get
your order and then and then by doing it
that way we've got a production team
ready to turn around the the orders a
lag super fast so when when we finish
taking orders for that week then we
print the exact amount that we sold and
we ship them immediately and how long
does it take for them to arrive from
their payment
points
it depends at which point during that
week they ordered it if they're the very
first people you know like we could be
chipping out the first orders and then
you know
to have it within a week that's
impressive well as soon as they order Oh
you mean after they the people in the
order at the beginning of the week if we
wait until the end of the week and then
print it then
those people are looking at like 10 days
right right yeah but uh if we have a
batch go out at the beginning
and then clean it up at the end but if
we have it in stock two or three days
right
but the whole idea is to not make more
than you're gonna sell right you don't
want to end up with a bunch of inventory
that you didn't sell and you don't want
to can't you just bring it on tour with
you or then you have to pay your taxes
we do we do that yeah and you also don't
want to leave a bunch of money on the
table by not having enough yeah so by
doing this pre-order way you you
definitely I'm gonna use that take the
guesswork I love that I'm actually in
the midst of launching my new clothing
company alien boy clothes ABC and so
this is one of the designs that I made
for it
and you're cool if I legally sell these
dude you can sell these can you look
into the camera Oliver Oliver tree can
sell these t-shirts until the
cows come out and you won't receive any
residuals yeah it's fine like you say
that into the camera I don't even want
any residuals I think you're a good man
you're such a legend bro and then the
cup how will we sell that
um
I mean dude this is just this this here
is arguably the most classic collab
piece of merchandise ever made we could
sell that on Stevo and do a 50 50. I'm
prepared to do 50 50. and I know that
because I'll be making enough with the
shirts that 50 I can lose on this
the with coffee mugs what's the trick
well dude we don't even have a trick and
I'm I'm losing my mind over this you
have a picture
maybe I can get one of yours I got a mug
shot yeah I'd love to give you one you
know what I think it's up in this top
cabinet okay there we go and the thing
with this with the design like that that
thing is just gonna sell itself
it's my legit mug shot on a mug so it's
a mug mug I love it man you look cold
man what did you do that was at my first
DUI how many times you've been to jail
uh many
I've not no I uh I have not yeah I've
been interested in jail many times how
many times ah it means I'll take it
actually I'll take it yeah
that I thought was the most genius thing
we've ever made everybody drinks coffee
it is it sells itself but but it didn't
like for some reason the weirdest thing
for some reason I could give you some
tips I think it's a little scary
it's a little dark I don't know I feel
like maybe we could have made a little
lighter more fun is it a black and white
photo we were working with to begin with
uh well you were saving money on colors
I don't know that that would have made a
Design This and get this if you want
help I'm willing to extend my hand
because the idea is genius the mug mug
could go big I think it's the color
combination and some of the actual
aesthetic of the mug maybe why what
color would you do oh man I would say
that for another conversation we could
talk business after the podcast here's
the thing is that I just don't know that
mugs are uh they don't sell like you
want them to yeah but we do a limited
run yeah I mean not just the questions
what's the turnaround time 24 hours okay
it takes phone calls to get the
Prototype oh the well that's the thing
the Prototype they had to build the
print now that the screen print is built
bro these things will fly off the
shelves all right I think I would be
inclined to go with the t-shirts okay do
a limited run I like that 50 50. uh
we're thinking more like a 75 25.
yeah
I'm I don't know
um No One's Gonna want to buy these I
don't know how many we would sell but
that's the thing if you do the pre-order
model right is this off like the Jackie
Chan and Chris Tucker yeah we might have
some copyright issues it looks like a
rush hour I base it off of Rush Hour
Loosely
allegedly I'll tell you what man
um I will cherish this t-shirt Until the
End of Time me too this is my favorite
shirt I wear it every single night I
love it man it's a it's I would say one
of my best designs okay so the next
thing I wanted to ask you is apparently
you have been beefing with bam and I
think that the marketing has been
incredible for your new skateboard with
Chris Pontius so I wanted to ask you
is he legit mad at you you think
yes well it's very hard you know but I
will say I have been working on
my own skateboard design my own line of
skateboards and I wanted to present you
the first one and just hear your
thoughts about it can we bring in the
skateboard
can you come in here can you bring it to
me please uh Scott can you not touch us
yeah I don't want to get your slimy
hands on it
go down that's a new one all right thank
you
so
I'm really really proud of this this is
my favorite design I've ever done you're
good you can go you're good to go home
now
um so this is a skateboard that is the
first copy of an entire lineup we've
printed out 10 000 of these things
already wow but I wanted to present you
the first one and I wanted to hear your
thoughts on how you would promote it so
okay
nice
all right Stevo and Oliver tree I mean
Jesus this thing sells itself
that's you it's an image it's us it's an
image of me and Oliver kissing each
other is that a mullet or a do-rag
that's my exact haircut I have right now
yeah that is uh he's partying his ass
off in the back it's the technically
speaking it's the bullet the bull cut
mullet yeah but yeah so what are your
thoughts how would I go about is it you
know an underground scooter rider not
really a skater what would be the best
way for me to try to sell this I love
that you gave me a little bit of a
goatee yeah I tried to just Spruce it up
a little week down down the line you're
getting some Beaver already
um yeah so uh this thing sells itself
um of course with skateboards like um it
is a piece of art and and and when you
sign it right so you'll be willing to
sign that yeah
okay cool I'll tell you um do you
actually sign the stuff yourself or
maybe one of you guys signs it yeah that
guy spent half my life should I get my
grubby hands on it
um I prefer if you didn't okay oh you
could look at it though so can you show
the camera because I want to make sure
they get a good shot
yeah we don't want to alienate our audio
only people so let's describe how
intimately we're kissing on this you can
it's clear just to have a Bud Light logo
it's beautiful okay so any thoughts is
there any one idea you know because I
thought you were really promoting this
new skateboard with Chris Paul it's
super super well and efficiently I was
wondering maybe how you could help me
promote my skateboard you guys should
reenact it that doesn't pull out
literally just about to say the same
thing I I have discovered recently as
you pointed out that
um beef sells
for the best friend's line I I would
propose that you and I
um
get very angry I think that would be for
sure I've used that one many times yeah
yeah uh best friends is the line right
you know uh we could maybe beef with
Bobby Lee and Andrew those guys are
jokes especially Bobby Lee
I mean
I think Bobby Lee's a little bit more
authentic I've I've beaten him up
multiple times I could take him down
he's like three feet tall yeah it might
be if he's more with Andrew Santina no
way yeah that's crazy what's the beef I
mean uh
he um wasn't particularly responsive to
uh text and then when he did respond he
uh he would pass me off and and blow me
off and what you wanted him on this we
made up come on yeah yeah he was too big
time he big timed me wow he Big Time me
but as Scott said we did make up and now
I'm willing to on makeup can you remind
me that text that you sent him get each
shot each shot
um but uh B I would like I would happily
on make up and Resurrect The Beef
because I think that would be the
strongest way to sell our skateboards so
me and Bobby was a bit different he
stole my hat we went to I was in
Koreatown and then me and my crew went
there and then I was wearing the super
cool beanie and Bobby Lee took it and
was wearing and I pulled it off and we
there's actually footage that leaked
online someone was filming it there's
footage of us physically fighting and
then we tried to make amends and I went
on his podcast and it just made things
worse and we had a physical altercation
multiple on his podcast
um okay that leads me to my next thing
um I have this new album coming out
alone in the crowd and I wanted to be
the first one to give you the first
person I have not given this anyway can
we bring in one of the uh I thought you
sent him home for the day well I'm not
sure if it's yeah sorry about that
so this is my new album alone in a crowd
I spent
um
the last three years making this but
really most of this year I was living in
Brazil and I was working on it there
trying to I wrote a lot of the new music
a lot of new material on it but this is
something I'm very proud of
um the vinyl this is a limited edition
vinyl because this is not the official
album cover I had to keep evolving it
and changing it and the songs are
slightly altered because you have to
turn in the vinyl nine months early and
so my version that gets released
digitally has been since evolved and
Amplified so this is the worst version
of the art and the music but it actually
makes it more valuable if you can
believe that but anyways this is my
third studio album alone in a crowd and
I was wondering is this uh the more
country no the country stuff didn't work
I had to give that up okay so this is
the third final installment this is the
last album I'll ever release so that
will make it even more valuable oh yeah
and
yeah yeah I could sign it too if you
guys got some kind of pen we would
probably need a silver one or something
though I don't know if Black's gonna
help
but yeah the uh black and red
red could work yeah
what's your uh yeah I gotta I got a ramp
I'm finishing up Escape I saw that damn
so hyped do I have to come through show
you how it's done damn so I've done it
it looks crazy and you're being a good
neighbor too I saw that yeah dude
um even I wasn't a good neighbor this
morning man what happened the
construction crew showed up at literally
like 6 30 in the morning by 7am
on your ramp yeah well they're building
a fence I think legally you can start at
seven oh yeah
if you start at 6 30 you'll get a fine
like you wouldn't believe 6 59 you're
seven you're good to go I
did not know that there's some yeah yeah
it's the red vinyl transparent red did
my brother my girl has a record player
at the house well I'm sure you're not
gonna listen to it but I would love to
give it a spin one day you're the first
person to ever hear it's not out yet no
one's is I haven't given one of these to
anybody so I thought I would give yeah
thank you for honor to you so in return
of me gifting to you how would you
promote this
um
music video like we talked about I'm not
I'm not out sorry
[Applause]
video that's already been done I filmed
three videos in Serbia and I made a
three-part series the third one's still
not out yet so I'm that is being taken
care of take it out too but I'm uh
really fascinated with this cover art
dude like uh is
is each person like their image was shot
separately and then all put together had
to composite them together
it's uh really really pretty killer
what's the only pretty killer I see how
it is
it's epic dude what uh is the musical
Direction here you said country didn't
work yeah so this is fusion
um I would call the genre alternative
pop but it goes from everything from Hip
Hop to dance music to Alternative pop
music electronic
um there is uh Rock in there too it's
it's Fusion
okay now check this out dude I have this
uh thing that I don't do nearly enough
what is it that um like
I I'm picking an album and I listen to
it on a loop belligerently over and over
nothing but that one album for weeks on
end said that I fuse the period of my
life that I'm in with that music and
said that for the rest of my life if I
ever hear anything from that album it
teleports me back to the time very
powerful thing yeah and I think uh I
think that I've decided to do that with
this wow you're gonna hear one song and
turn it off no I don't know that's
happened with some albums but I don't
think that's gonna happen well the thing
is if you don't like one song just go to
the next one because there's such
diversity in it that there's gonna be
one thing that you could love in there
and I've heard your rap music it's it's
pretty similar it's pretty uh what do
you call it aggressive yeah very
interesting that's an understatement
okay so
um you said this is not out yet no it
comes out September 29th so this is your
early you're at at the beginning but I
wanted to I I had to beg the label and I
I asked label I was like can I give
Steve a one and they said no we don't
want him to leak it out I was like that
would be the greatest thing we could
ever do fans like buy this and leak
it out themselves they like find these
gateways in the system and are able to
exploit it and then they yeah see my
music and sell it so I mean I was like
if Steve wanted to I'm not gonna I would
be lucky I'm not gonna I would be happy
if you did actually well I'm not gonna
leak it dude it's not crazy that was
their response was yeah we're concerned
that he's gonna leak it I was like it's
vinyl the dude would have to go through
a lot of trouble to try to leave this
out and I was like and if he did we it
would be the greatest thing that he
could do for us
yeah dude well I I don't know you
wouldn't know how to promote it I I I'm
bad at music well you could do a stunt
or something too yeah that's like you
specifically it would be great if Stevo
did a proper stunt no but if I for me is
there anything you can think of just the
worst idea anything that comes to mind
um
I think that when it comes to music you
want to get the music
two people so like I mean do you want to
uh right now
um
acapella I think I'm good okay
let's look at the track list here if
there's something that's particularly
salacious you could draw attention to
that like uh we've got uh the first
track is called Bounce it's about sex
bounce it's bouncing up and down on
all right that's good you want to let
people know that
I'll let people know I'll maybe have to
put that in parentheses on a digital
yeah bounce up and down on Deez Nuts I
like that you could do the remix we'll
get you on a rap first yeah yeah okay
good I went outside here ugly side yep
ugly side
what's that about
someone's you know other side to them
decide that maybe isn't uh let's just
say the most um
the side that they like to show people
but the side that comes out when maybe
you know you see the real them or they
have something to lose you know I think
people don't tend to show
okay too much of themselves until you
maybe they don't get what they want and
then you start to see other sides to
people that wasn't my first assumption
my first guess would have been that oh
this person yeah they're kind of on the
ugly side like us you know but yeah
anyways you don't need to go through the
whole tracklist but anyways I appreciate
you even taking the time to listen to it
yeah and I think that uh
it's masterful I think that that is
um in and of itself a very solid way to
promote something by simply presenting
it to somebody and asking them how they
would promote it because really what
you're doing is promoting it by doing
that maybe potentially can we bring in
the next thing um is my guy still here
he's just waiting out there in the sun
poor guy
Turbo
so oh yeah bring this in
this is something I got for you you
could put up in your house probably
right above your bed
nice so this is my tour alone in a crowd
that's sick the tour uh and it's a movie
because I'm performing the movie live
um as a play and as a concert and a TV
show and a movie
um so and I got the dates here you can
see well Ricky's gonna be there across
the board from New Zealand Australia I
go through Europe and into the UK so my
my question is to you
first of all what do you think I I think
it's fantastic I think uh you got Aqua
starting in New Zealand all right
um
this is all International no America
we're not even touring It in America
only overseas
strong
yeah I found it does better overseas
yeah okay good good
um
yeah so uh so what would you do to
promote this
I mean because I'm thinking about maybe
taking it to some podcasts do you have
any suggestions of like podcasts that
would be good for me to take maybe try
to promote the tour on
um I think that you uh have a pretty
strong
podcast
uh
Network
you're hitting all the the The Heavy
Hitters like you you just do the ones
you're doing okay next question how
would you promote it is there some kind
of stunt that you would do is there
anything that comes to mind because your
execution on both the last two
performances that you you filmed the new
one right buckets so those probably some
of the best promotion I've seen I mean
the only person who even takes Toe to
Toe even by one baby toe is maybe Logan
Paul there's a couple people like that
who come to mind that are pretty legit
marketing guys super good but you are on
another level and you're willing to risk
it all so is there anything that comes
to mind how you would promote this tour
alone in a crowd
I think
this is gonna sell itself dog I mean
like you did Red Rocks like what's
capacity there fifteen thousand I think
it's only like eight or nine so it's not
that big still pretty damn sick
um collabs so so stuff the the marker ba
Rivier
do you know that guy oh yeah I think I
know of him yeah yeah he puts together
yeah yeah I think uh
get together with him I think uh yeah
I've got some cool openers I got swaco
and Tommy Cash number one guy in Estonia
then Little Ricky and supercomputer my
ax will be coming to all the shows so
there's a pretty crazy lineup I'm very
proud of this but uh maybe we put this
right in front of the camera so we can
get a shot of it the whole time yeah we
can just maybe park it there for the
remainder
I love it thank you yeah you can put it
down I think this is uh you've done a
fantastic job putting more gifts did you
bring well actually
to do a miniature interview can we bring
in my interview stuff
this you're gonna freaking love what's
up with the hair dude
freaking bowl cuts falling off so I want
to present you this 100 questions with
Dr Stephen Gilchrist Glover so can we
can you show this so this one's legit
dude don't touch that okay I'll be
taking it from here
so I've worked very hard
I've watched every Jackass movie for the
eighth time every episode of wild boys
I've pieced together a very in-depth
interview so do you mind if I ask you a
couple questions please please okay
give me a second
thing is still I I bought like six of
these things and they literally none of
them fit my eye I have small eyes
okay so I'm just gonna
you need something to write on
um
a skateboard could be good yeah
so
first things first
I got this set up this is how I'm kind
of old-fashioned and I like to kind of
keep it old school
so I have this hand written onto a
scroll and this is a hundred questions
okay Stevo okay
let's see here
okay I want to write this down
all right first things first
what's the worst thing you've ever done
oh the worst thing I've ever done
uh I'll tell you one that comes to mind
um my buddy Tommy had to say Tommy Who
Tommy card deal he uh had this idea we
called it the Poo handle and like to go
to a gym and like some big like but can
you slow it down
muscular guy like watch him get out and
walk into the gym and then go and Tuck a
piece of poo under his door handle
someone you said the last part again
take a piece of poo under his door
handles out of the gym like uh
uh you know he's knuckled deep and and
Pooh as he reaches under his car door
handle so how'd that play out well I
didn't do it I'm so embarrassed to admit
this and it was in the 90s okay
I I pulled down this chick
did you film it yeah I think I did like
uh I think I did like um I definitely I
filmed I don't know what happened to the
footage like uh it's like why doesn't
even do that you know like
here's the 90s Jesus
I just move on to the next question we
have a limited time here okay this one I
think you're gonna like
who do you hate the most in the jackass
crew
um
who do I hate
the most
I'm pretty angry at all of them right
now why is that well because I I uh
invited I sent them all an invite to my
skate party
what was the goal of the skate party
just
I got my new ramp you got your new
boards on sale now
maybe that's it all right okay
fair enough
um okay all right this next one is I'm
gonna have a panic attack if you go
through a hundred just I'll make I'll
make it quick okay
it's in your mouth B's covering your
dick taking beerbongs up your butthole
what does your dad think about your
stunts
um my dad is able to
compartmentalize he sees uh the business
um
like uh potentially see he's able to be
supportive of the business of what I do
while not being in love with the
creative of what I do okay that's fair
enough all right we can keep moving
faster
um what do you think about making a Best
Friends TV show where you and I go
around the world and get into crazy
hijinks and shenanigans I don't know I'm
all for it dude that's my only problem
is uh being at the mercy of uh corporate
establishment no corporate and you know
yeah like just put on YouTube kind of a
thing yeah yeah we'll pay for it 55
about 25.75 yeah okay cool you'll do the
75. yeah good good okay but yeah we'll
talk about that I'll pay the 75 for the
budget but you keep 75 of the profits
does that sound right yeah okay okay
um when I was a kid me and my cousin
used to watch Jackass and we would play
this game called dumbass and we would
throw ourselves down the staircase how
does it feel knowing you inspired a
generation of kids breaking their arms
um I got some headlines not long ago
when I
acknowledged that in the beginning of
Jackass when the media wasn't so
fragmented when there wasn't any YouTube
and stuff that like jackass was
legitimately I thought I would say a bad
influence
but
in the many years since then I think you
can't really point the there's so many
different ways to point the finger I
don't feel right culpable 100 all right
you can only pick one
jackass or Wild Boys
[Music]
be real Stevo
this isn't about money this isn't about
ratings what was more fun
if you could only do one for the rest of
your life what would you choose
good question
um
do one for the rest of your life yeah
I'm gonna go with jackass and and
um I'm gonna qualify that with uh
just the you know there were certain
situations with the wild boys
um word
I didn't feel good about how animals
were treated I could see that
um and now a lot of people say yeah well
you guys mistreat animals on jackass
like
didn't Peter come after you they yeah
I'm much more comfortable with the way
animals were used on jackass than in
certain cases on wild boys
um I'm not going to defend every use of
animals on jackass and it's not my
decision whether they get used or not
yeah but I'm more comfortable with
jackass is there a favorite Wild Boy
story that comes to mind after all the
traveling you did
um
wild boys story
um that I'll refer you to our Wild Ride
episode with Jeff Tremaine okay uh we
really really dug into this one we don't
need to bother
um
do you ever go back to Brazil I know
that you moved there when you were six
months went there for wild boys don't
believe I've been back so I was gonna
ask if you went after wild boys it's an
incredible place man I recorded most of
this album here Julio de Janeiro and I
was I was in this glass house on top of
the hill in the jungle and I'll just go
to the beach every day and then go
record it's a magical place you should
go back for not work purposes one day
um shout out Brazil
um okay moving forward
um let's see here
were you on drugs for wild boys I was
how did you acquire drugs in these
different territories is that hard
because you seem pretty out of it for
some of it and Chris too he looked yeah
we did a lot of drinking okay drinking
yeah but you were you doing hard stuff
or no a lot of drinking I smuggled weed
to
um just about every place that I
couldn't be confident in finding weed
um and uh you know with respect to the
harder drugs
um the wild boys would actually
represent
um
little intervals in between drug vendors
I would typically be still awake for
days on end cocaine Bender when we went
to the airport to start the wild boys
trip it would be like a day of travel
like a day of act you know and then by
the time we're shooting I've kind of
recovered from the bender and and I'm
not on hard drugs so the sleep
deprivation carried some of the
yeah yeah
wild boys was in it was a crazy chapter
in my life man
how about being sober now being around
people who are up like when you
see someone super drunk or how does it
make you feel
um what's your tolerance for
I'm not uh
too concerned with it I mean I don't
really care to be around people who are
super you know intoxicated
um but with that said like I spent 11
years in sobriety touring comedy clubs
where people have to drink you know it's
like to drink minimum
not a problem being around it yeah what
about someone asks you the same
question four times in a row never have
anywhere they're so drunk yeah
what are you tell me you're gonna be
here and it's like a loop it's so crazy
Cena
um when you get off of a comedy tour do
you find that you feel depressed
sometimes no I just want to get home to
my my animal because you know like for
me after a tour like especially a big
one I get like like from hearing
the screaming every night and the crazy
energy and then going back to being a
normal person and doing laundry can kind
of feel a little bit like from a high
standpoint the high is so high and then
you go down to normalcy and there's a
you crash you have a huh you never have
that you know experience um
that's not something that
um I relate to too much it only started
recently when the shows got bigger for
me okay the highs got more intense I
think I like that but it's so I'm sober
doing it but I'm just noticed that like
I like that and I'm questioning myself
why don't I have that it might be a
music thing it happens with music like
musicians get depressed sometimes after
the time because I don't know yeah I
just think that um you know touring can
be like kind of grueling and it's just
like oh I really want to get home
especially like with my animals at home
and I just want to like get back like
whatever this first flight is after the
last show like I typically want to be on
that and get home as soon as I can yeah
that makes sense and you have
is it your partner is your wife or no uh
we're getting married soon finally we've
been engaged looking forward to the
getting the invitation yeah I'll be
there I'll be wearing this it's going to
be in Tennessee I can't wait I love
Tennessee good I'll be there um send me
the uh the dates and I'll be setting it
up yeah we'll have a date soon I can't
wait man I'm happy for you maybe our
wedding DJ bro I'll be there have you
done I'm not cheap but I put on a hell
of a show yeah I love it
um what about I wanted to ask you about
your drug abuse side effects as you've
gotten older do you start to feel
certain things more do you find the
is now that you're sober do you not
really feel like you have much effects
or do you feel like as you've gotten
older you're like oh my back from all
the Ecstasy or something like that I'm
starting to like I'm noticing issues
with my right hip which are kind of
bothering me and I'm gonna guess it's
not from drugs though no okay so this is
you're just getting older yeah all your
stunts
because I just built this awesome ramp
and it's like uncomfortable to skate it
is it pop in and out it doesn't pop in
and out but I can definitely notice like
go back to Stem Cell yeah I don't know
maybe
so when you see footage of yourself on
drugs do you recognize that person do
you see it does it seem like it's
someone else like you're watching
someone else or does it feel like you're
like oh that was me I remember it very
well I remember it very well and there's
something about seeing footage of me on
drugs that uh it it almost like makes me
relive it like I can really like like I
remember it too well well you know like
it makes me a little bit uncomfortable
because it kind of puts me back in that
time so after the drug stopped what did
your addictions hop to
sex food
um
spending money uh those are like the
main things yeah like um
it just it's a dumb on it and if I
if I open up my Amazon app and uh
there's no presence coming
like I feel a little bit empty wow like
I like to always know that I've got
presents coming for me I don't live
anywhere like I don't have an address or
live anywhere this is my manager's house
okay so I don't actually collect stuff I
don't buy things for me it's more the
collecting of the money just stacking it
oh there you go but it's kind of like
you know at a certain point you want to
live somewhere so I'm hoping to be able
to get a proper spot but yeah I
definitely like I mean I buy pretty
negligible stuff on Amazon so um
I'm not like when I say spending like I
don't have like a really flashy
lifestyle you know like uh
but um but yeah I definitely want to set
myself up with savings so that I can um
retire and live comfortably and not be
like a lot of uh
entertainment industry people who went
way past the time they should have gone
what about doing stunts sober versus
being up did it compare much or
no they have a saying if you take away
uh the alcohol from a horse thief you
got a sober horse thief I'm a sober
attention
so nothing changed pretty much I mean
there was some acclimation to sobriety
but uh but yeah the will to do the
stunts was never
um because of drugs and alcohol it was
because I'm an attention
yeah all right we'll question real quick
I know this has played out but for you
what's either the scariest stunt that
you ever did or that someone in the crew
did that like when you think about like
what was the most gnarly maybe for
yourself or anyone in the entire crew
what what comes to buying just Bulls so
Johnny stuff yeah Johnny's stuff with
bowls that last one really did in
numbers yeah they recover fully yeah
I would say sorry I mean like there's
concern with with concussions that like
actually that you know it's a super
delayed effect and so the damage is done
but it won't really uh present for until
later so you know you gotta have a
concern that is there um you know is the
Reckoning
to come you know and like that's that's
scary does he still have a stutter I saw
he got kind of like a Stutter from the
head injury uh I don't I don't know
Knoxville to stutter no I just saw some
interviews where he was talking and he
would kind of like speak his speaking it
was probably right after it happened
maybe you didn't notice that I don't
know how to say I monitor my clone my
communication with Knoxville pretty
closely
um what percentage of a shot is
um God I hope it looked good
um and is gonna make the video or like
versus the actual pain of it because I
know that
it doesn't look good enough you're and
so how much of it are you kind of like
playing up the reaction not to if you
don't want to talk about that it's okay
but I know you guys are doing stuff that
could kill you and it's super risky but
I know that there it is a movie I don't
think I don't think anybody's playing up
a reaction you never think so
I I don't think so and um
I think that the that the the barometer
like if there's a metric for whether a
jackass bit Works It's the reaction of
the guys the peanut gallery right right
right like uh if the guys aren't
giggling yeah then it didn't work if the
guys are giggling then it then it worked
and I don't think uh the peanut gallery
of guys you know watching something
happen is ever gonna pretend to giggle
if they don't find something funny right
um what's the worst thing you've eaten
for a stunt
ah worst thing I've eaten first done
um
yeah I mean there's been some pretty
terrible stuff uh maybe Preston sweat oh
probably the closest
yeah that was rough I've seen that a few
times
um so I guess
I wonder sometimes what goes through
your mind while it starts happening like
when the shark that seems like one of
the gnarliest ones for you was when the
shark when you hit your foot against the
shark you like kicked it was that up
there with one of the most scary ones
for you yeah dude I'm really excited
that um I've just finished up a video I
made with Chris Pontius called uh 10
times we could have died wow so you
cover this up I I I literally went
through your mind I saved that video for
a long time man like I've got like sort
of the Silver Bullet collection you know
and like was there something that you
were thinking when I was having you just
like get me out
you know
accountable for anything I did around
sharks I don't know I don't know why but
that one had occurred to me well like
that could have been really bad
yeah are you shocked that
that things didn't turn out worse for
what you guys had done here's what you
think there was a level of calculation
with most of the stuff that was
practical enough that you
I think that there were a lot of close
calls there were a lot of risks that
um you know I wouldn't be necessarily
comfortable taking at this point in my
life
um but with that said everything that
that we did
um
we approached it like
with the idea of getting away with it
yeah do you feel like jackass and wild
boys would be the same as what it was if
it came out today or do you feel like
with like cancel culture and the rules
and Appropriations different things that
it couldn't have even existed obviously
you made jackass 4. but that had even
that had to shift its tone a little bit
I think that a jackass has aged pretty
well because it's devoid of like you
know any bad intention you know it's
like I'm not saying that was bad
intention the spirit of it was was very
uh positive wild boys wild boys they're
they're a lot of things that wouldn't
age I feel like yeah I was watching it
and I'm like that's crazy but like you
know also it's just from a very
different time period right there
there's stuff on wild boys that wouldn't
age well like you know that would be
considered appropriation yeah
um but at the same time like the the
spirit of what we were doing like uh was
it was never
a negative you know yeah I know that
there wasn't the intention we were
really ambassadors of Goodwill and I
think in a lot of ways you could have
the mindset of someone could say oh this
is appropriation but for your like
representing the culture even though
you're maybe not the guy to do it right
and you're like you know I'm sure some
of the people were like oh like this is
like well right like showing off our
culture to new people in the world and
there's something to be said about that
but that's another conversation right I
remember like before my last Australia
tour I pulled a clip of uh Pontius and I
dressed up as um aboriginals with
aboriginals like throwing boomerangs it
was classic as Pontius through this
Boomerang and it came back and it nailed
him in the head and he was bleeding on
from his head like it was just a classic
bit but um you know the people who uh
are close to me sadda dude that's not
gonna play well you know even though we
were with like
native Aboriginal Australian people who
dressed us up themselves I would imagine
that that kind of um
makes it a little bit less offensive but
you're right you know you go anywhere
near that and and people get get real
bent out of shape
um but I stand by the the spirit and the
intent so this I want to word right but
this is something I thought about which
I don't know
um if people have brought this
correlation to you and you might not see
any connection with this but I feel like
jackass was born during a time that was
extremely homophobic and you guys came
along wearing your g strings getting
naked with the Bros showing off your
asses or shoving things up them touching
each other's dicks drinking animal semen
you guys seem to normalize male nudity
which is still even a taboo thing in
this day in America
I feel like you guys were almost allies
to the queer community in an interesting
way
I know well I'm just I'm saying
suggesting because you didn't see this
but from my outside it's like there's
even the Rainbow on the Dick house
production logo which that's very
obvious but I was just gonna ask
um
how much of that was a conscious
decision
I think that there's something uh
the the we got a kick out of like making
homophobic people uncomfortable you know
like there's kind of a sense of like the
The Jock bro you know like which I'm
sure is a large part of the audience
right right yeah like uh and you guys
are reaction based you know yeah they
can't get the the full reaction so that
probably plays into that too yeah if we
were targeting anybody it would have
been uh you know like homophobic jock
frat dude kind of mentality but it's
interesting because I feel like there's
almost like with hazing and things like
that they almost like explore that
themselves in a way that like for them
makes it okay maybe I don't know but
anyways I just was curious because I saw
that like the logo even at the beginning
I was like right and how much rainbows
even play into like the intro outro of
like bird movie or whatever it's like
obviously there's some some clear I
think that like like there's something
about
um an ability to not take oneself
seriously yeah that that that's that's
really at the heart of of Jackass and um
I think that when when when guys
are taking themselves super seriously
like that's uh you know there's a lot of
uh overlap with
kind of homophobia I think right
um I was gonna say is there any kind of
ground rules that happened before the
filming of a movie like is there certain
things you're like you can't do this
like if you're like before you go into
production or is it just like the Only
Rule is there's no rules like fight club
stuff
um
it's like uh there's a lot of
sensitivity to
um just the spirit of of what what we're
doing yeah the number one rule is uh you
know respect and um
like with regards to third party you
know never
put your hands on never like uh you know
be mean-spirited never you know like
to ourselves and each other like there's
basically no rules like you know was
there physical altercations that ever
arose from it they're a couple is that
you can't talk about that kind of stuff
I'm happy to talk about it what happened
here just from like the reaction from
something because like I could only
imagine that from the beginning of the
movie to the end the tensions are
building certain people are getting back
at each other uh the Pontius Wrestled a
number of people like mostly danger
Aaron
um didn't danger and Bam almost get into
it too man I think bam kind of maybe
beat up danger yeah it seems like Aaron
kind of gets the low end of the totem
danger socks Dave England on tour yeah
on a tour
but there's never that's not like any uh
do you ever have any beef on the filming
nah I saw him wild boys like you were
punching Chris in the airplane or
something and then like he can't he got
so pissed because he's sleeping and he
got up you were like and he was in the
first class or different like oh do you
know
I seen him come like and just punch you
the Black Mamba I think yeah
that's uh punching Chris Pontius is a
dangerous move I I can't remember a time
when uh I was bold enough to do that
yeah um I'm sure maybe you were coming
off a bender yeah mid-flight on your way
on to the next adventure definitely a
lot of gnarly flights did you guys ever
have like safe words or certain things
where like when the bit was done you
needed to sit because I remember there's
one in sequence where like and this is
different because it's a dog but like
Johnny is getting his butt bitten by
like a dog and he yells Oklahoma yeah
Oklahoma I was just curious that was for
every skit or Justice that's the only
safe word I'm aware of but you guys
would use it if something was cross the
line I said Oklahoma when they uh
connected my balls to a rat zapper
electrocution machine was it it was I
don't remember that is it used in yeah
did it get you I think it might have
been in a 3.5
so how much stunts are actually filmed
for the sequence and how much don't make
it in either the 0.5s or like the
credits very little very little doesn't
get doesn't get exploited in some
fashion right because I was gonna that's
a pretty cool way that you can make two
movies out of it how did the the 0.5s do
compared to the did they even get
theatrical uh no theatrical the straight
to DVD but it's like a bonus straight to
DVD except for the 4.5 was uh Netflix
exclusive now now I'm seeing people uh
kind of crying out for um physical
copies of uh 4.5 which I don't believe
exist
um and and they should because there are
a lot of people who collect physical
media what's your favorite part of a
filming a jackass maybe what's your
least favorite part
uh
getting the shot is of course the
favorite part when you get to be like
we're done yeah it's like for the day
there's I mean what Jackass is is a
battle of attention for screen
time you know we're we're battling for
screen time and and just when you get
the shot and you
and you got the screen time like that's
just a battle one
did you guys ever lose footage like is
there any time with wild boys or jackass
or any scenes that like you wish would
have made it or something that got
erased like a story I refer to the
Tremaine episode again but there was a
photo that uh that's known as the
greatest photo ever taken I think well
there's a couple of those
um and uh I was in a compromising
situation with um a prostitute in
Indonesia and there was like quite the
perfect photo taken like through the
window
and they were like multiple people in
the room that I weren't wasn't even
aware of and uh so I was like mid thrust
and it was like the peanut gallery in
the room and like this phone and and uh
I destroyed the hotel room made of super
temper tantrum and demanded does the
photo be deleted the photo was deleted
and that like is the most
um
sorely grieved
loss of media for you or for the rest uh
not necessarily for me you're happy I
don't know that I'm happy like I could
have been your enter into the porn star
there's one more career path that could
have happened there yeah I don't know
how I feel about it because I don't even
know that I ever saw the photo but um
but certainly like if you ask anybody in
connection with wild boys they would
probably say that that was the most
grieved lost media does Lance the filmer
who is always throwing up does he get
paid extra to be on camera
um
I don't know about yeah I think so I
think that he's got a talent deal I
think he's got a problem he's like he's
got to get something for that was it
like so if you talk you get sag or is it
like something like that yeah I think
that Lance get has a producer deal and a
talent deal and like you know whatever
is filming
you know like uh
yeah I think I think he does pretty well
I know you maybe have spoken of this
already but um I can't remember I
remember there was something about it
but with movie payment you don't have to
talk about if you don't want to but is
it like was your deal structured flat
fee or residuals for the movies there
would be an upfront piece so you get an
advance up front yeah there's an upfront
piece and then there's the back end
consideration profit participation or
points and was that always across the
board or after the first one or the
second one you sent some president for
that yeah the first one I remember the
movie The First movie we got uh
like the minimum scale and then and as I
understand it it was Knoxville it was
like Hey we're making a movie the guys
are getting some back end after that
we're during the movie the show was like
going into the first movie which I
thought was really cool and then um
there's been uh back end since then and
you were able to kind of fight for more
of it as the movie yeah fighting for
more became a thing like only for me did
it become a thing on the fourth movie
but yeah like I remember hearing
something about that what was the I just
always found out what I was gonna get I
was like oh cool and then come the
fourth movie I was like man I should
have maybe tried to like push back and
fight for more so it was my first time
ever trying to fight for more on the
fourth movie you think that was because
you had built your profile up yeah on
Jackass 2 and you recognized more of
your words I thought so yeah I thought
so but um in hindsight I didn't do
myself or anybody else any favors by uh
approaching it the way that I did we
went on into the media with it yeah one
of the media is kind of a bad look and
and um
I uh you know I I ended up making amends
you know or like acknowledging that I
handled it all pretty poorly
real quick our camera's about to die and
you have a you have a voodoo photo shoot
oh okay soon do you want to ask
whatever how many last ones I get
out talk to me like that Scott I'm gonna
cut this one before I have three more
pages that one's good yeah I think
should I go to the end yeah that's good
okay I'm gonna cut this before it dies
so it doesn't corrupt any footage sure
okay we got that one and that one all
right this one's at six
you weren't kidding about 100 questions
yeah that's why I came I was gonna
interview you that was my main plan okay
I love it
um Okay so
yeah
all right this one yeah I can keep going
or you need a second can you cut this do
you want me to cut it yeah cut that one
it's about to die
this one's has a few left okay all right
hear me out hear me out this wasn't as
much
I'm trying to make a proper
documentation it's not as much for me as
it is for your family I'll give you the
guinnessful book of records for long as
well I'll have to ask you these other
questions at another point maybe I'll
call you
um and I'll spread it to your Reddit
forums okay so um I'll get to the end
here because I'm not I'm being pushed
off the set understandably
um but I am gonna get some residuals to
come over on Saturday I'd love to yeah
dude what do we is that the big Escape
yeah well I'm not gonna SVP for that
all right all right if you could go back
in time is there anything you would
change in your journey through life I
I'm protective of the space-time
Continuum I learned that from Back to
the Future okay yeah that's good I like
where I'm at now and I I don't want to
mess with it
do you believe the journey to becoming
the legend they call Stevo was your free
will or your destiny
oh you know
um
I
I believe that Free Will is uh and
immutable
unbreakable love the universe
um
so predestination
I don't think really is in the cards but
then again you got like your
I don't know man I don't know I think
that uh tough one it is it's a tough one
I think that
ah
I think that you can't
you can't there's no way around free
will to just give somebody a
predetermined outcome I think that I
came into this life with
um
like just a persistence not even
necessarily a good persistence like I'm
just like the most like annoyingly
persistent bastard so I think that my
free will coupled with my persistence
was a recipe
for uh what happened but I always think
why are we persistent why are we
passionate you know and it's like is
that free will at that point too uh I
think that that as
um on a soul level I do believe that we
choose our parents that we you know like
outline a blueprint for what we're
supposed to do in life and and we go
into it so like I think that
ahead of time before my life began like
on a soul level I equipped myself with
certain
characteristics which which
by definition were predetermined but
then once once you pop out of that womb
then uh
yeah all right I'm getting close here I
know you guys are ready to get out where
do you see yourself in 10 years do you
think you're still be shooting yourself
in the sky and porta potties covered and
pretty far out
um
I think that the that the world as we
know it societies we know it I picture
being
dramatically different in 10 years right
I think that like I would even say like
on the level of like the fall of the
Roman Empire type different you know
like
um
maybe maybe not maybe maybe I'm talking
20 years but I think that the societies
we know it has a very limited amount of
time wow so you think it's all coming to
an end not necessarily coming to an end
I think that the gravy train is coming
to an end and I think that uh that I I
would imagine the the Great Depression
of 1929 right is effectively chicken
compared to where we're headed
crazy um so you're a doomsday prepper a
little bit yeah a little bit 20 29. is
that the year I don't know I mean who
knows you know um but with that said
um I definitely have a limited amount of
time left to really beat myself up yeah
will you retire you think I've got I
mean I think I I retire from piecemeal
from certain things right like I've
already thrown in the towel on standing
um back flips that's good
not kicking like uh there's certain
things but um
you know who knows I'm gonna evolve I'm
gonna like I'll probably always be an
attention Corp but um I I'm working to
set up
um like a property with the animals and
the animal sanctuary deal like I love
that last question when you die what do
you want people to remember Stevo as
um
what do you want them to remember about
you my ego really wants uh people to
remember me fondly having entertained
them you know like uh
that bad that I want them to
remember me as somebody who's loved
um but that that's just ego talking I
think um if I have a legacy then uh I'd
like it to be
um
like with with these animals in our
sanctuary
I wish you luck on that Journey thanks
Doug
yeah thanks for making time
security stuff yeah dude you're an
impressive cat brother after all that do
you really have three testicles
that will never know no I do I was born
with a condition yeah and they used to
make money you calling Oliver three they
did they used to call me Oliver three it
was kind of uh I don't like to talk
about it
head out
[Laughter]
we shattered the record for the longest
episode of The Wild Ride podcast ever
what was it before like hovering around
an hour and a half yeah Kevin Smith
probably was the longest before that
yeah and this one was two and a half
hours unbelievable it's like an hour
longer than our longest and it didn't
feel like two and a half hours
this dude this dude is Bonkers man he's
like
he's like my new favorite guy I'm dying
to see his show his live show I don't
doubt that he puts every little bit into
it that he says he does
man I feel like we got to know the real
guy and I really like the real guy and I
really like you because you stuck around
for the longest part we got to
do something special here if you're
still listening or watching this deep
into the long the very end of the
longest podcast we ever did
then
I need you to
an agent
[Music]
post something like do the street team
thing but but put hashtag
what hashtag street team bonkers
because I'm going to be looking for that
man
that retention dude that I was like
nervous I was like we're going so
long like man her attention falls off
like because that's me too I'm a psycho
all right guys I love you thank you for
sticking around hashtag street team
bonkers